Yeah.
Uh,
the,
yeah.
Hey everybody,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe Rogan Dalton [inaudible],
click on the link for the fleshlight and entering the code name.
Rogan,
you will get 15% often number one sex toy for men.
And then you can watch pornography with it.
And then you shoot your little loads in it and you're all happy now.
Aren't you happy?
Buckle up bitches.
Tom [inaudible] in the house.
All my girls back.
[inaudible]
Shizam bitches.
Welcome back.
Welcome back to a Garosa.
Yo,
what's up brother?
What's up man?
It's good to have you buddy.
Thanks for having me,
man.
We're going to be doing the Ice House in Pasadena this weekend.
Um,
so it's,
it's a fun place,
man.
That's the one of those old school places.
I think they've been open for 30 years now or something crazy.
Yeah,
they've uh,
they've been opened over,
I think,
don't they claim to be the oldest?
How many classes?
I think they might be,
it's them and light.
Then the comedy and Magic Club is regret up in there too.
Yeah.
And then the store I think,
but if you go there,
it's one of those places that has like,
it's a like a fucking comedy museum as well as a standup comic clearly.
Cool.
That's the coolest part.
Yeah,
because you're walking around and you see headshots from like the 70s man,
the head shots when the ATS tracks.
Yeah.
I saw a David Letterman and contract last time I was there and his social
security numbers on it,
but it'll cover like by the frame and I'm like,
damn,
if you really wanted David Letterman social security now or you would just steal
this picture and break that frame you just gave somebody.
Wow,
why did you get some back?
Did you bring that up to us before the podcast?
And we say,
yeah,
maybe we shouldn't talk about that on the air.
And you go,
yeah,
I guess you're right.
Well you got to talk to the Ice House.
I'll be there tomorrow night.
Tickets on sale,
free coupon code on Twitter.
They have other kinds.
They didn't alternate it at all.
They didn't,
I don't know.
They,
they might have,
but I was looking at it and I was like,
Holy Shit,
why is that just sitting there?
Right.
Like,
that seems like they would know that by now,
you know,
it has to be altered.
I must be altered,
I would assume.
Hopefully Jesus Christ,
I'm just a crook looking at a fucking headshots and I'm like,
wow.
They busted a bunch of those anonymous cats,
Huh?
Yeah.
Shitload of them.
Some in California too.
And what do they charge them with?
I don't know.
That's like cyber terrorism or something like that.
That,
that's,
yeah,
that's hardcore federal.
What did they do exactly?
I know they went after companies that thought were bad and they hacked pay
power.
I think they did.
Or they fucked with paypal somehow and I can't remember.
And they like started taking people's pay pals and like buying things on Amazon.
Like,
but it was all fun stuff.
Like they would buy like diapers to the right person or something like that.
And uh,
things like that.
But it was hacking paypal,
which I guess can be considered like a bank or something like that.
So that would be a federal crime,
I would imagine.
Yeah,
they're fucked,
Huh?
Yeah.
You're getting real trouble for that shit now.
I guess cybercrime is legit now.
It's like terrorism.
Like remember they used to not have laws for this stuff.
Like cause it didn't like when people would do things like this for the first
time and people would,
they would get like,
we don't really have a law yet for breaking into this type of account cause they
didn't know their shit existed so they had to pass all these laws.
We still have to pass laws for new crimes.
You know what I mean?
Technology allows for new crimes that take place.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Crimes that didn't exist before.
They weren't possible for you.
Remember when they first started using those things over the phone when they
would have tones that you could call Andy and use over the phone and it would
like hack the phones.
What the fuck was that?
Yeah.
What,
how,
how did that work?
I can't even remember.
I don't,
I never,
something you could do to a phone by sending a tone through it and that certain
tone would interact with the machine on the other side.
And I don't know what the fuck that it allowed you to do,
but just the fact that somebody figured that out,
man.
Yeah.
People are so creepy.
There's,
they'll try to exploit every little,
you know,
and,
and any little system,
there's gotta be some way to make money off this.
That's why I see somewhere to hack it.
Security never becomes foolproof because yeah,
when you develop a new security system,
it becomes someone's mission to break that.
So then you just make it as good as it can be and then you have to evolve that.
But you kind of need those guys though,
because if you don't have those guys,
you don't have any realistic sense of how secure your data is.
Oh yeah.
You know,
you need some fucking psychos going after your shit,
you know?
If psychos go off to your website,
then you then,
you know,
then you know,
because you can't just have your employees.
Well,
we're going to test it from the outside and see if we can whack in.
Nah,
you don't have enough motivation.
Stupid.
Yeah.
You need to be hating the government.
Did you tweet that article about the guy who is going to prison now for like
life or something for hacking his neighbors?
Yeah,
he's going for 18 years.
Well this,
he was terrorizing the family.
He is a crazy,
amazing story.
Pharrell story.
You hear shit about that.
It's scary.
Scary story.
We can just do that.
That's terrible.
I think as a business,
the only way to protect herself from like these like hacks,
like anonymous and stuff like that.
It's just to have a shitload of cats on your website,
you know?
So if it's like wells Fargo Bank just put cats all over the place cause I think
that's how crazy this shit is.
Like do this anonymous and stuff is,
it seems like they're only attacking people and unless you're,
you don't get the Internet,
you know,
it's almost like,
hey,
if you like cats and if you're like piracy and torrents and,
and shit like that,
then you're on our side.
But if you're,
it's almost like it's like a gang,
like an internet gang,
you know?
What are you saying?
I don't know.
Understand why shame.
It's connections to like,
uh,
four Chan as,
as an example and things like that.
Even if it's not,
they're not on in four Chan or whatever.
Like it's four.
Chan supports them.
Yeah.
And then,
and then Lil Louis,
Louis sac or with low sacrad like supports a anonymous,
almost like it.
You just almost have to be in some kind of gang and just have a lot of cats on
your website,
I think to protect you.
And what is the cats on the website?
Because that's like saying,
Hey,
I,
I'm on the Internet too.
I like cats and hamburgers and what the fuck are you talking about?
You,
you really need to go to a doctor.
If you think anything in that sentence when they sentence,
you need to go to a doctor.
I did not follow.
All right.
You want me to explain it?
No,
no,
no.
Definitely not.
The thing that,
no,
let's move on from that.
Fuck.
Are you dog?
You can't.
The thing the best.
I know what you're saying though,
that it seems like they're in kind of a gang and it does seem like,
sorry,
I honestly didn't follow,
I'm sorry.
All right.
You know the Internet,
what's popular on the internet caps and hats and shit like that.
Like a cat's really that popular on the Internet.
Fuck.
Yeah.
It's like it's porn cats.
Real business.
Is this what happened to Egypt when Egypt went down?
Cat Worship.
They got to look at us the same way.
You know,
maybe this is what cat worship is.
If you looked around people's fucking houses,
are those your cat?
Well,
your thing that you have with the,
the cat with the dynamite on it.
Yeah.
That lucky cat.
How many porcelain cats are all throughout people's homes?
Huh?
There's a lot of Williams.
Yeah.
There's a lot if you like,
if archeologists came here from the future,
they'd be like,
they might say,
well they were this weird cat worshiping group of fucking ran environmentally
conscious freaks.
Yeah.
Cats are running shit.
And then they would find out about the toxo plasma shit and they would make some
half ass hypothesis that the reason why we were so fascinated with cats as we
all had toxo.
Sure.
That's true.
And that's what made us all go crazy.
Do you think that we uh,
wrong,
like,
uh,
inaccurately,
get an idea of like past civilizations like,
Oh,
you have to be right?
Like where you're like,
here's what they used to do.
Well,
in my mind,
man,
thousand years ago,
what fucks my mind is shit like sue mayor because there's only a fucking handful
of people who can read that shit.
That's cuneiform.
I think it's called.
And it's these weird lines and man,
it takes forever to translate that shit.
And there's a lot of discrepancies.
It's,
that's why that whole Zechariah Cichon movement,
if you're not aware of that,
this is,
you know,
the Zechariah snitching Shit,
right?
That's that.
He believes that in his study of the Sumerian texts,
this guy was like a legit scholar on ancient languages.
And he believed that his,
through his study of the ancient Sumerian texts,
he believed that it was a detailed account of how the human beings were created
by an advanced intellect called the Annunaki.
And that they mixed their DNA with us.
And he says,
this is all in this ancient text.
And it's very disputed.
There's a lot of people that don't agree with them,
a lot of like mainstream,
you know,
scholars from that era.
They don't agree with them.
But this guy stuck to his fucking guns and,
and he,
he believed that the entire human race was created by these,
you know,
these things called the Annunaki and this is all written down.
What really fucks my mind is whether or not that's what they wrote down or what,
who knows what crazy person wrote?
Whatever you're reading,
you know,
what you're reading doesn't necessarily represent the whole world.
What if you stumbled onto a pile of ancient Stephen King books?
You know,
I mean,
who the fuck knows who the fuck knows what exactly you're reading when,
but it's,
it fucks my mind that you can go that far back with people.
It's like you can really trace progress,
but things get lost somewhere along the way.
And there's a few places where it's like,
they'll just stumble on some shit and go,
whoa,
Whoa,
whoa.
Where'd this come from?
Troy?
You mean Troy is real?
This is a real city.
What the fuck?
Now recently Atlantis,
they found Atlantis in Spain.
They,
they're almost positive.
It has the concentric rings.
It looks just like it.
It's in the right area.
And they,
there's all the illy.
Yeah,
there's,
there's also,
um,
there's,
there's also some interesting evidence that there was a models of Atlantis that
resembled this,
this place,
and they had been passed down like in the images so closely matched and had all
these symbols in it represented like symbols of Atlantis.
And it's just way too close.
Like a lot of scholars are getting on board with this.
They think they found it.
So that's like so much shit is there.
They're always finding ancient shit.
It's like the civilization has gone so fucking far,
but we can't really follow it in a straight line.
No,
but especially after like before a certain time.
Yeah.
When you can't like 2000 BC.
Oh Man,
son.
How long ago was that?
And you notice,
you know,
when those things get like really old ones,
they get like,
they're like,
this is a civilization.
It's 40,000 years old and they,
they'll,
you know,
they'll read something on the wall.
They never,
uh,
I take into account the possibility that it's art.
It's always like,
they're like,
this is the document,
this is like documentation showing that they loved whales and that they would
fuck here and talked to the son here and then eat the whale.
Now this is what they did in their day.
And you go,
but what if it was just somebody painting or drawing?
Like they never,
that's never really a pull when human beings first figured out how to
communicate for sure right away they started lying right away.
Right.
I mean,
as soon as they realize they can lie and get away with things.
And then you don't get in trouble for stuff.
It was,
people just started lying for sure.
It's just,
it has to be old as fuck.
It seems like just an inherent like escape door in,
in consciousness,
the ability to communicate but then give deceptive communication and fuck with
other people.
So from,
from right away people were probably untrustworthy and especially in their
depictions of the past,
especially when they're talking about like things that happened.
I mean,
Jesus Christ,
everybody knows that the winners write the history books and you know,
back then the history books were written on animal skins.
You know,
who the fuck,
what really
happened?
You know,
it's like,
it's very shady at best and you don't,
you never portray yourself really in a negative lab or shameful.
Yeah,
no one's,
no one's a bad guy.
If it's you,
I mean it's,
I mean that's of course there's,
you know,
different cultures and have different depictions of the steam store and you can
kind of extrapolate from all those who's probably got it right.
But it's a lot of gray area,
man.
She was talking about,
you know,
thousands and thousands of years ago and then they constantly have to move the
date.
They found that place in Turkey recently over the last decade or so,
I believe it's called go Beckley and it predates anything by like 5,000 years.
It's like 12 13,000 years old.
Yeah,
no like fuck.
Like we didn't even think people were making shit by,
yeah,
they thought that back then people were just strictly hunter gatherers,
so there's all sorts of light and they don't know that anything about that
culture.
They're like,
what is this?
You know,
why do they have lizards on there on these rocks that they've carved out these
giant columns with lizards on me and this one's got a sheep on it.
What the fuck were they doing?
Just all the stuff for the,
what is this?
The lines of Nascar I've ever seen,
man,
dude may trip and there are so enormous,
the whole thing.
I mean,
I know that this is obviously what everyone says about it,
but it really blows your mind when you think about it.
The only way you could see what you're doing is if you're in the air.
There's no other way to see how well you did this and these things are so old
that like how is,
how could you check it out?
I mean the,
the,
the lines are as wide as roads.
Yeah,
the roads.
Yeah.
Wide earns.
Perfect.
Yeah.
Perfect lines.
And the only way like you see crop,
like they do it on farms,
right?
Like they'll do like fun things,
but the only way they're seeing what they're doing,
if somebody is in a plane and radioing like now here drive six yards.
Well the guys who make the crop circles don't have to do that.
The guys who make the crop circles,
what they figured out how to do is they just mark some numbers down.
They figured out like distance.
He's like,
this is God.
They call themselves a circle makers and they've shown that you can make
certain,
you know,
certain pretty intricate grab circles.
But what's amazing about this is we know that there's air flight.
Now we know that people are going to see these crop circles mean if people made
these things for fun or for High Jinks,
if that's why they're making these crop circles,
these beautiful designs,
just to make people go,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
We know that people are going to see him from a plane.
So the idea that these can only be seen from the sky,
it's like who are you making them for?
Right.
And the fact that there thousands and thousands of years old,
it's the point where they don't really know exactly.
Is that,
do we not even know?
They don't really know.
No,
they don't know why.
They don't know who.
They don't know what it symbolizes.
They don't know if the fucking mountain was flattened out.
By the way,
do you know there's an area where the Nazca lines is that it looks like it was
fucking excavate.
Excavate,
excavated.
Excuse me.
It looks like it was excavated.
It looks like it was flattened out.
It looks like it was sculpted.
It looks,
it was worked
on by machines.
I don't know if it was,
but I wouldn't be fucking completely surprised that there wasn't some very
sophisticated level of humanity at one point in time that died off and dropped
back.
You know?
I don't know if they were ever as far as we were,
but who knows,
man,
when you see shit like that,
there might have been some people flying fucking planes three or 4,000 years
ago.
That might've been real.
That could be,
it might be.
It might be.
It's,
it's fucking why.
Well,
why else would they draw those things,
man?
Why would they do that?
They're incredible.
Giant,
massive and that,
yeah,
it's,
what's the purpose from this guy?
You're supposed to look at it from the sky.
You,
you know you're doing it just for the satisfaction of knowing that someone can
look at it from this guy really,
and this is going to be like a common practice in a place where it looks like
there's runways and it's also,
it's not only you have to see from this guy,
it's out of the way in the sky.
Like that shit is way out of the way.
Maybe back then?
No,
you didn't really understand life.
So you're like,
I know there's something up there that it storms on us.
We,
we've heard thunder.
I'm going to make a sign to a piece to the god,
you know,
so you might be not like a plane,
but it's more like a,
like a ritual for stability.
Absolutely.
Sure.
That's possible.
Like the,
you have to consider more as the straight lines.
They're looking like runways.
They're all over the place up there.
Huge.
It looks like God Damn Logan Airport.
That's what it looks like.
It looks like an airport.
Like there's all these runways.
What's those big statues that ha like we're big rectangles that had their mouths
open.
Uh,
and they had like a,
you know what I'm talking about it and they used it in a gratis video game
island.
East islands.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well that's a trip to,
yeah,
that's a mean.
Tasha is awesome.
They really,
they,
they struggled to figure out how they move those stones thousands and thousands
of years ago.
How they cut them so.
Well,
Machu Picchu is like that too.
Yeah.
Like those stones
or no shit.
Like the size of like the wall behind you and they lay in to another stone like
this.
They're like,
you can't slide a piece of paper between them and you go,
you look at these like boulders.
Basically.
They're smooth.
They're like,
they're shaped.
They're massive.
So you go like this would take hundreds of people and then how would you get it
to fit into the next rock where it looks like they're made for each other?
Yeah.
It's unbelievable.
It's pretty deep shit.
Yeah.
And you see how a la,
I've been there.
I've been there three times to that place.
Too much a patriot.
Really?
Yeah.
Is it cold trip?
Like is it,
would you recommend going as it like a vacation?
Literally blow your mind every time.
Every time.
What does it like,
what does it feel like when you're up there?
Isn't it?
First of all,
it wasn't like 10,000 feet above sea level.
Something crazy.
I don't think it's that high up.
It's that mean it's in the Andes.
You,
you fly to,
to Cusco in the south of Peru and then you take a train from Cusco to,
by the way,
if I was a single girl and you're telling me all this,
I'd be so attracted to,
I feel like he's a man of the world
and has been done match you,
Pete,
chewy.
So amazing.
I think I can get them to go vegan and he recommended Amarillo.
That'd be like
the Fart Porn,
the 7,900 feet above sea level.
That's where up man.
And they have no idea how old that shit is either.
Right now they have estimations for that.
I mean it was definitely discovered by a,
they,
I think they said that they were there in the fifties and sixties they think it
was been one,
I think it was 1560s you know,
that's one of those disputed ones with 'em,
that Graham Hancock Guy,
and I know a lot of people are this or pseudo science and he's the guy,
the guy that predates all these.
I'm like structures.
Like he's got a thing on the Great Sphinx with this other guy,
a doctor Robert Schoch out of a University of Massachusetts or Boston University
rather,
and they think that the Sphinx is like thousands and thousands of years older
than everybody thinks it is.
Then conventionally Egyptologists claiming as well,
he's,
he's also got a thing about Macha Picchu that they think at one time match beach
who was actually on the shores of some water.
Really?
Yeah.
That it was on the shores of a river or a lake or an ocean or something like
that.
It is stunning it.
Fuck.
The thing is like,
it really puts in like this is true about everything that the magnitude and like
the greatness of something,
you can't measure it.
It doesn't matter how many videos or photos used to see it.
It's like it's whether,
you know,
it's like seeing a band live or seeing a person who's like just has some
same Thompson Garner the ice house this weekend,
Friday,
Saturday night show,
sold out both nights pitches.
Did you tag the statues?
What's that?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
Area.
You suggested today ever dear cool.
About a PD on those things?
Oh yeah,
I'm sure.
Want to see graffiti?
Have you seen graffiti?
That's cool.
Yeah.
Dude,
that's like a safe place.
That'd be awful.
So tell us a story.
I'm sorry you got,
I'm just making fun of you being so attractive with your knowledge.
You get in a bus or a train and you get somewhere.
So how does it go?
Yeah.
What you fly into Cusco,
which is way up,
uh,
up in the,
in the mountain.
This is all in Peru.
In Peru.
Yeah.
So when you,
when you arrive in Cusco,
you're up high already.
Cusco is pretty high up in the mountains and you get like powerful headaches,
you know,
headaches you getting in like high altitude places.
Uh,
but I,
I'm pretty sure it's higher than like,
you know,
uh,
Tahoe or any place like that where you're like,
oh man,
like,
like a head hurts cause you have serious oxygen deprivation.
And then in Peru they chew coca leaves and they drink coca tea.
The tea leaves that are used to make cocaine.
I had that shit that Moscow,
the cocoa.
I did not like it.
I've never done cocaine.
I've always been terrified.
Terrified of it.
Yeah.
But um,
I knew that people,
when they did coke,
that kitten shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
So I,
I drank this tea and I couldn't shut the fuck up.
Really?
And it was saying that was with Doug Stan hope.
And I was telling him,
I'm like,
dude,
I can't shut the fuck up.
I go and literally I can't
shut the fuck up him on cocaine.
That seems insane.
I would love to have a video of you on cocaine.
Does not fired up.
I don't think.
I want to know that.
That's even possible.
I don't want to be any,
any more intense than I am.
I'm good.
I don't need that shit.
That's a horror movie right there.
Joe Rogan on cocaine this summer.
He turns in some hands doing,
you're doing standup.
I'll cocaine.
Oh,
just all angry and fucking like a punk rock.
And somebody who knows you and you just throw them out.
You like Ron,
our test.
You just jump out in the stands and start beating somebody accusing Rauner.
Jessica doing cocaine maybe.
Wow.
You know what?
Just strong words.
Joe Rogan on cocaine would look like slept wrong.
Step Tim,
get at me.
Put me on your show.
Joe Rogan on cocaine would look like that rise of the planet apes trailer that
you haven't seen yet.
I've seen that.
Isn't that fucking insane?
A monkey movie.
I thought you meant a documentary.
No.
Rise.
The planet of the Apes.
Look,
look,
those shoots.
Amazing.
August 5th bitches.
I'm a little child,
bro.
I'll take clearly AP.
You can redo that shit from me every two years.
I'm a dummy.
You can have a new script where I know what's going to happen every couple of
years and you got me.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm just going to tell you right now,
I commit myself to all you people making planet of the apes movies.
I commit myself.
Come out with a new one every two years and you got me.
I promise you I will buy the Blu Ray.
I will support you.
I will talk about how good it is on Twitter.
Please keep coming with the crazy monkey movies.
Crazy monkey.
Oh the shit dude.
This one.
So it looks like the researchers like are you fucking with a eight and they
break out and,
well,
this is sort of what's supposed to be the prequel to planet of the apes.
This is what caused the problems.
Oh,
this is the idea of planet of the apes is a guy goes to the future,
right?
And lands in the future and that essentially run by monkeys.
You think about the CGI.
Incredible.
Now it does have that little fake look and I'm sure it's still got a little bit
of that I am legend Shit going on.
When you look in their faces,
they don't quite have it,
man.
It's interesting that they can't do living things quite right.
Wow.
I wonder if there's going to be any heartwarming moments.
They,
it seems like there's gonna be some heartwarming moments.
Let me tell you something.
If you saw a chimp that look that you liked this champ,
you would start screaming the fact that they were all cool with that.
Yeah.
This is weird.
If you saw that chimp,
that ship would be a huge internet hit.
Oh,
I didn't know Dexter Morgan was in this.
Wow.
I haven't seen this one.
This is like bad ass preview Jonathan Lipo and uh,
yeah.
Just a moment.
This is the full one.
They,
this would shows you where they fucked up.
They raised a chimp.
That was their little buddy and they locked him up in a jail.
Oh my God.
So it's got a good fucking comeback sets to it.
You root for the chimps.
You realize what conscious human beings are and you root for the chimps.
Is that the log line for the movie?
Yes.
That's the way I'm promoting.
I'm promoting it on sort of a separate underground labels,
sort of division of the movie.
This is what we do now.
We sort of do shit behind the scenes.
Wow.
That's exciting.
Fuck these people.
That's how,
that's our promotion.
This is one of those amazing trailers I've ever seen.
He is intense.
The last thing you ever want is a chimp coming at you,
man.
That is the last thing you ever want.
You're almost better off with a lion because the lion is just going to kill you
quick.
Chimps are going to do some shit to you before you die by your fingers or
they're going to,
they're not trying to kill you.
They're trying to hurt you.
They understand what makes you a person and they don't have morals.
They understand what's important to you.
They understand your genitals mean a lot to you.
So the bike those off.
Yeah.
They understand that your fingers are important for you to,
to use to make things.
So they bite all those off next.
Yeah.
And they do all this without you being able to do a goddamn thing to stop it.
Nothing.
Because they're so fucking strong and once they bite one finger off,
dude,
you're going to be freaking out.
You're going to be in shock.
You're not gonna be able to handle it for him.
It's another day in the park.
He's been biting fingers off since he was two.
Yeah.
You know someone's step soon wrong.
Who Bites a couple of fingers off.
That's just what they do and strong as fuck.
Can't even wrap your head around how strong a champion's dude.
We had a two year old chip on a set of news radio,
a two year old little baby ass chimp.
This thing was on my back and it's swatted me in the back a couple of times and
I swear to God,
I got nervous.
It made me nervous cause I was thinking like,
what if a cat wanted to kill me?
You know,
if a cat wanted to kill me,
that's terrifying.
Right?
Cats or you know,
I mean even though they're little like that fucking crazy thing coming at you
trying to kill it.
Yeah,
that would be terrifying.
You know,
and you're way,
way bigger than a cat.
And I was thinking,
how much bigger is this chimp than a cat?
And at this champ decided to just fuck me up.
I'm not really sure I could defend myself.
He's a two year old chimp and I'm not.
I'm not really sure that I would get off.
And then I thought about it and I think,
my God,
what must it be like when they're like 150 pounds?
It must be unbelievable.
The amount of force they can generate with their bodies must get you some
shocking.
They can rip car doors off their hinges.
Yeah,
do you can lock a car door and they can just open it.
They can open that.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
Fuck that right today.
That lady,
they tour with their hands.
They tore her jaw out of her face and lower jaw came out,
you know.
Oh my God.
God Damn.
That's,
yeah,
there's scary,
scary fucking creatures.
It's so funny that we always want to like look at them like they're real cute
too.
Like Bj Mckee and this is my best friend bear band.
It was the best smoking the band and have a monkey.
Wait,
what was the one of the monkey?
No,
Curtis would,
Clint Eastwood had a Orangutang every which way,
but loose.
That's the one that's,
the partner has no idea what he's talking about.
Being in the band.
Some of the best moments in my childhood,
it was that guy with the monkey who which one?
Oh yeah.
Burt Reynolds.
I was like,
fine,
but they all came out at the same time.
There was like that car chase movie then there was kind of monkeys.
No I don't.
I think every movie in that time period had a monkey.
It seemed like a strong move by Clint Eastwood to go from Spaghetti Westerns to
the bad ass,
bare knuckle fist fighter with a monkey has event.
Well the orangutan,
those movies were great man every which way but loose.
They were great fucking movies for sure.
And what's even more fascinating about those movies is that's when he was still
married to that woman,
Sandra Locke,
the woman who had gone to sue him and he had to get her some sort of a deal to
get out of switch.
Yeah.
Had to get her some sort of a deal with a production company as a part of their
divorce.
And he did.
And then,
you know,
she accused him of sabotaging her projects and their projects bringing,
going.
Like,
it was obvious that this guy fucked up like poor Clint Eastwood married this
crazy broad,
you know,
and was with her for years and you know,
she's an actress and when they broke up,
man,
she just fucking went after him and,
and you,
you know,
you got to see the nastiness that that can happen and those sort of like really
public divorces between two fucking movie stars at the time.
I mean,
she never really worked again after that.
Not much.
I mean,
I've done not have that level,
but she wasn't a lot of clinics.
So it's movies and the amount of money that exchanges hands and a divorce like
that.
Oh Man.
Oh No.
So you got to see like him with her back in the day.
That's when he was still with her,
you know,
and it was like,
wow,
how weird is this?
This dude like Carrie,
this tick around and a bunch of movies.
Yeah.
How many movies did cleanings would do it shot Sondra Locke.
How many?
It was the,
it was a western,
right.
It wasn't her one western.
And then there was every which way but loose.
Right.
Or one of those.
Any which way you can.
Which one was it?
Was it both of them was at all of them?
All of them.
I Dunno.
It's fast.
It is fast.
You forget to like,
you know,
we always like,
they always talk about who makes like crazy money and movies and so if they're
like,
you know,
so and so like got $100 million divorce and they're like,
who is it?
And like Tom Cruise,
you're like,
yeah,
well that dude's like super like he's a moneymaking machine.
But then like Morgan Freeman who you're like,
yeah,
Morgan Freeman,
he's great and he's a great actor.
He's been a lot of movies.
He got divorced,
I think he gave,
I want to say like over 70 million.
Oh.
So we were like,
Holy Shit,
how much fucking money does Morgan Freeman and you know Morgan's Freeman's deal
right now.
Morgan Freeman is apparently banging his non for what?
It's his grandmother,
granddaughter from his Ex Wife's side who is not related to by blood.
Huh?
Yeah.
Some for him.
Something super creepy like that.
That's crazy.
And he started taking her to events and introducing her as his granddaughter.
Oh yeah.
And then somewhere along the line it came out that he was banging her.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And everybody's like,
what the fuck?
You're so good and accurate.
Morgan Freeman,
I don't care.
I know that's how maybe with stone and he thinks it's really funny.
Stills don't right now.
You mean listen,
he,
you know what?
Here's what the deal is.
He's like,
what,
70 years old?
Yeah,
I think so.
At least 25 year old pussy is so powerful.
It will get you to abandon your morals,
your idea.
You like the bull yet you will rationalize the shit out of his.
Yeah,
I've known her since she was a baby,
but we're not like related by blood.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
But they never get met.
Plus he does so good.
Cause he's an old,
old man.
You know,
she's young and tight and she's trying to rock him because she likes the
spotlight.
She likes the fact that she's,
you know,
throwing some pussy at Morgan Freeman or is it the best payback ever to your ex
wife or he's the one who goes after it.
He couldn't be a creep to,
you've got to look at it that way.
Sure.
It could have been Hawkin her,
you know,
his whole life and waiting for her to turn 18 and start putting it to her.
How about the dude who just married the 16 year old haven't lost.
You have the guy from La Woo,
she's 16 where her fucking parents,
man,
they were cool with it.
That's the crazy part.
Your parents have to,
if you're 16 in Vegas and you want to get married,
you have to get like permission.
Yeah.
And I think it was probably set up for teen pregnancies and shit like that.
Somebody's trying to do the right thing.
Yeah.
Fucking a man.
Her parents were just like,
we look,
we love lost.
Why
is a great show?
We'll get guys like that.
Is he done?
The guy's done.
Right?
Yeah.
You can't go around Mary and 16 year olds.
People kind of want to hang out with you,
man.
This,
this ain't the 1950s and you're not Jerry Lee Lewis.
No.
You know what I mean?
You can't marry that girl.
That's crazy.
That's got to keep him from jobs too.
Like there's a few directors or producers out there who would consider that dude
for a job and then hear that and go in that man.
What,
um,
what's the other guy's name?
Let's get you on the phone.
Yeah.
Listen,
he's not that good.
Right.
I'm going to say that that's not worth the show unless it was some sort of a
reality show based on the two of them that that could work.
Yeah.
That could work or reality show based on a 16 year old,
but it really be unfair to the 16 year old because you know,
when you were 16 years old,
would you really want some document out there of who you were and how you behave
when you were 16 and the whole world can look at it whenever they want,
especially when you fucked up and you married some 51 year old dude,
you know,
well,
why should everybody be able to look into your shit?
You're not really old enough to understand what the fuck that means.
Yet you're not really old enough to understand the ramifications of the whole
world.
Being able to look in on that,
you know,
so that you couldn't have a reality show with her.
I think about how little I think about how little you knew when you were 16 oh
my God,
I was such a fucking Douche bag.
Yeah,
man.
I was like,
imagine if you had to meet yourself today and hang out with yourself.
It's a 16 year old.
I'd be like,
seriously?
Just to shut the fuck up.
Just shut the fuck up.
Dude.
I tell you,
I found it.
I'll just give myself a hug.
I found a video of my son would probably need a slow kiss.
I found a video of myself.
I took a camera,
uh,
camcorder to a party when I was 18.
Oh my God.
Right.
And a,
it was like,
I'm a senior in high school and I walked through and I just talked to people and
I put the camera on myself and I'm just doing this for like 30 minutes at this
party.
I watched the video,
I took it out and then I broke the tape and I burned it.
Really?
Whoa.
Yeah.
And it wasn't anything incriminating.
It was just,
I was so,
it was like a really rapid,
like instinctive response to how much I loathed myself as an 18.
I was like,
that's fucking embarrassing.
I don't want anybody to see that.
And I told her I was like not nostalgic or like,
that'd be cool to show it to my kid.
I'd be like,
I hope my kids never could find that.
Wow.
Because I was fucking like,
Hey,
what's up buddy?
What's over like
myself?
And it was fucking horrifying.
You think about like the shit you did when you were like,
we're like,
wait,
shit.
You yelled out to people and like,
I was like,
that's fucking embarrassing my,
you know,
the thing is though,
you're going to think it's,
you think it's embarrassing now,
but you're going to wish once you have kids have,
I know I fucked up.
I know all my shit online and I've had it on,
you know,
from when I was 15 I have a movie called carrots that I did to like,
18 I had this movie where me and my friends just smoked weed and got drunk and
we're hanging out in this one bedroom apartment like I have all this gets stuck
and I just,
you know what,
I'm just putting it out there.
I know it's embarrassing.
It makes me look like shit or bad,
but that's only myself telling me that,
you know,
it's like,
it doesn't,
people once,
once you have children of your own and you start thinking about the process of
going from being a baby to actually being a human and all the shit you have to
learn along the way,
then it's going to be fascinating to,
you.
Sure ain't gonna wish you had it because yeah.
Before I had babies,
I probably would've looked at it differently.
Like I don't want any evidence that I was a retard.
You know,
like there's some video of me from Rascal's comedy hour in New Jersey.
I was like 24,
25 of June,
beautiful,
delicious head of hair and I'm fucking real skinny.
I didn't even lift the weights back then and uh,
I'm doing standup.
I was like,
Oh God.
So dorky.
Yeah,
my shirts Dorky.
I look Dorky,
like sound.
I sound Hacky,
like eh,
but it's cool.
I liked it.
It's out there.
I bet if I saw that video right now,
I would be laughing.
My fucking cute cute.
I can show you.
I can show you old standup.
I mean old like seven,
eight years old where you don't,
you don't recognize the way I look or really,
really long hair like flowing locks,
like just like really thin and happy.
It's weird how people's voices change over the years.
You know?
I hear my voice when I was younger and things and I'm like,
wow,
my voice was so high pitched.
Yeah.
It's still like a boy,
you know?
It's weird.
You know?
I'm really selling what I'm saying to them.
Like,
you know,
like I'm really like,
over a high tone to your voice that happens like after you become 30 where you
become like a man.
You know,
there's,
when you're younger you don't even realize it,
but you have this weird high pitch to your,
to your voice.
Yeah.
I always thought it was cigarettes that for you.
For you.
Yeah.
You never really became a man.
It's just cigarettes.
Make it sound like one when I'm,
when I'm,
when you went at 50 it's going to be full circle.
You're going to be on something to treat Duke cancer that you have from
cigarette smoke and it's gonna make you develop even more estrogen.
That's what's going to fight the cancer.
And then you're going to sound like large Marge from peewee's big adventure.
Tell him large large sent Ya.
Yeah.
That's going to be you.
You're going to sound like an old lady.
Did you guys see the pee wee Herman a live show?
They have it on.
I know we or something.
No,
they haven't on HBO or showtime.
They filmed his live show.
Live show.
What does he do?
He brought back.
Oh,
get the fuck out of here.
Yeah,
it's sold out everywhere.
Of course it did.
Yeah.
It is so weird to watch this and adult though.
I uh,
my class is 80 and doing it.
That's the creepy thing.
He did it at that Nokia Club.
Like the theater,
but like the smaller of the two downtown.
Yeah.
And my cousin went and he said that it was just,
it's all people like,
uh,
you know,
like they would say lines at the same time.
Like it was like seeing like a band or something,
you know?
They would all look at each chosen an astrologer thing.
Oh absolutely.
Yeah.
Everybody in that theater is like,
did you,
did you grow up with weird Al Yankovic?
Yeah,
sure.
I just got his new album.
That is the funniest shit ever.
That guy is still has it man.
Really ridiculous to listen to when you're just really big to driving on the
highway.
You'll sit there and giggle the whole fucking way home.
We got to get him on your podcast.
That would be awesome.
I was always a fan of weird Al Yankovic when I was a kid.
I thought he was hilarious.
I'm fat.
I would always wait for his new shit to come out when he came out with I'm fat.
You know Roy big,
big country.
Nelson still goes into the octagon with that song.
No,
he enters with that song.
He's the only fighter that enters on a weird Al Yankovic.
That's pretty.
That's pretty awesome.
Fuck you like that guy a lot.
How can he not like that guy?
I remember good guys got the best personality.
He's,
he's so talented too,
you know,
and he's just trying to lose some weight.
He's trying to like earliest get in better shape and yeah,
he's just,
you know,
super talented.
It's just,
he's not in the best physical condition.
God Damn.
He's got a great personality though.
I have,
I have a video of myself at like eight years old with my cousin who is eight and
my other cousins nine and we've seen I'm fat
and have that a talent show and we're all skinny.
But I hog the mic and I'm the one that ended up fat,
like of the three of us put that online dude.
Like I would get really into it.
Yeah,
you should definitely put some of that stuff somewhere.
no,
I thought I wouldn't get rid of it,
but I'm going.
No,
you should.
You should put that on the next DVD.
But yeah,
we do a DVD.
Have that as be as one of the extras.
Yeah,
I should.
why not?
That's hilarious.
And I also have college college sketches that we made were like,
we had like a,
we did a commercial,
a fake commercial for a product called anal freeze and it was like for like when
like when you have diarrhea.
I just was like,
I have diarrhea.
I'm like,
well why don't you use Angel Freezer?
It will freeze all that crap up.
Like that's the tag.
It'll freeze all that crap up and then like it's horrible and be like it comes
in a bottle and you just shove the whole bottle up your ass.
We have videos of that type of genius had highbrow stuff.
Oh that's hilarious.
That and like a Kung,
a fake Kung Fu
short where like we like layer Wu Tang music and we have like a Kung Fu.
That's why no one can ever be cocky about where you are.
Don't be disrespectful about other people's material.
Yeah,
yeah.
They might suck right now,
but guess at one point in time you suck too a lot.
You sucks a lot.
A lot.
Everybody does.
Yeah.
You can't,
not second you start on anything.
You want to suck.
The best part though is at that time you don't know.
You think you're good.
There was a bunch of times where I was like open mic nights and I couldn't get
on.
I was like man I'm going to get up there.
I'll fucking show these people what's up.
And meanwhile I was terrible.
I shouldn't not have had any confidence whatsoever know that I can go up there
and make people laugh.
I was awful.
I shouldn't have been allowed to talk ever.
I should have been practicing with only people barely spoke English for the
years to work my way is the main stream.
But that's just how it is.
Right?
Absolutely.
I remember like you remember like when you have,
when you finally have like 10 or 15 minutes down that kills and then something
happens one night where like you just don't know how to react to a room.
Oh so it doesn't kill it actually bombs.
This is the shit.
Like this is the best material at all time.
Best thing I got my toolbox and you have nothing else to go to.
That is like a paralyzing feeling and then you realize cause you'd killed with
it so many times you get a feeling of being kind of invincible and then when it
doesn't kill your like maybe Oh shit.
Like maybe this isn't amazed.
Like that's where you wish you had a real job.
It's like God,
if I just had a job I'd be like reporting back to the stockholder as well.
We have a discrepancy between the projected income and the actual income.
We're going to give you some figures on this on Monday,
but it's nothing we can't fix.
Yeah.
But when you're out there and saw all you,
your Thompson who are incorporated and you're eating a dick,
eating huge,
you know,
what would you like me to do?
Boss can't.
They can't say that because what you're doing is you're the boss,
you're the boss,
you're the Ed.
The end of the line is you stupid.
And if you're doing it and you don't know how to dance like now if like
something like if it were to be like,
man this,
that was really,
that was what that job bombed or something happened.
You have the tools after a while to adjust to that.
The problem then is that like you just don't even know how to it like and you
panic and they found they panic for you.
Yes.
They see the panic and then they're like,
oh,
we're all panicking.
Like then you're in a fucking elevator fire.
Like people are just like,
how the fuck do we get out of here?
I was a recently,
I saw a friend of mine and he fucked up a joke and then after you fucked up a
joke,
he started rushing the next joke because you could feel that he fucked up and
that joke bombed and then I felt like the spin,
I felt the spin,
the slide and my,
my toes started crunching up on my shoes.
I clenched my hands together.
He pulled himself out of it,
but I almost had to leave the room.
Really?
Yeah.
He got a couple of good laughs and then the ball started rolling again.
That was like,
okay,
we're back.
But it's the uncomfortable thing of watching someone's slide down the road to
bombed them.
Yeah.
I don't want to be there for
that.
It's,
it's,
it's really painful.
I don't need to see that dude.
I know.
It sucks.
That's why I ride a lot.
Yeah.
And you can almost do you doing over there and Brian,
you and Justin sounds thinking little thing.
Yeah.
Why don't you tell us when you're doing that,
otherwise it freaks me the fuck out.
Oh Man.
Of course.
Are My ears getting way better,
Joe,
you got to watch,
look at the Salvia video that Tom was talking about earlier.
This is going to be the one that when Tom got here,
the on the first things you said is,
dude,
you got to see this video,
this couple smoking Salvia.
And why is it so interesting that it has a million fucking hits on Youtube?
Cause what happens in it?
Yeah.
Even though Ari Shaffir when he did Salvia and I heard you freaked out.
Oh yeah,
you gotta check out that video.
I saw a little bits of it,
but yeah,
yeah.
From his account in times that times that by a billion,
and this is 126,000 people are seeing this right here.
Just this one.
It's uploaded like a million times on here.
Yeah.
So they're,
they're recording themselves doing Salvey,
which a lot of people do.
Yeah.
What is the big deal about that?
How'd that all get going?
Because you,
you leave your body like it's only a couple minutes,
so you,
you're really interested to see what happens,
you know,
cause you're out of it,
but you're awake type thing when everybody does it the same way you guys did it
with Ari and what I would imagine it's like the worst environment possible.
Yeah.
When you're filming these fucking things.
So the worst environment possible this do takes some rips off this bone.
Yeah.
Like he,
I mean I can't say what that does for people don't know what the Fuck Salvia is.
Feet squares out there.
Salvia is a super powerful psychedelic drug,
but is a very legal for some weird reason.
Yeah.
It was one that was missed in the whole sweeping psychedelic drug acts of the
1970s whatever it was,
1970 when they made everything illegal,
somehow or another,
they miss Salvia.
So these people are taking something and other laugh and their balls off.
Yeah,
it's a hundred times more powerful than marijuana and you can buy it in head
shops legally.
It's like this is normal shit.
Like people laughing right time.
Then the Ari Shaffir factory.
It just takes a turn almost.
See the moment.
There you go.
That's it.
Okay.
So now a chance you guys lying down and listened.
He's having such a good time and now all of a sudden he looks kind of freaked
out.
One thing to note is that the camera's off tilted.
Like why is it not centered?
This is one of the best advertisements ever for don't do drugs.
That's what I'm saying.
That's why I think it might be a fake,
but it's really good acting.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh,
he's breaking windows,
Bro.
This ain't fake.
Yeah,
no way.
No Way.
Yeah.
And those are trees up there,
man.
You're on the second.
No Way.
Yeah.
And then she kind of just comes to it.
It's like,
Ooh,
oh my God.
And then part two,
you saw part two,
right?
Yeah.
Part two.
She's just totally,
what'd you just say?
Part two.
This is fake,
but somebody just fake.
Yeah.
That's,
that's don't do drug video.
Right.
This looks fake to me.
Okay.
Um,
I don't like the way he,
he randomly stumbled into the window.
I don't like is that the camera is not centered.
It's,
it's actually so you can see both windows like the couches to the right of the
camera and has a camera man.
If you're sending up yourself record,
why won't you zoom in on the couch?
You're not going to sit at that far back.
And it showed that much window.
And why is it showing its off centered?
I always thought it was fake,
but I wanted to see what you guys thought as soon as fake.
The way he moves seems fake.
Yeah.
The way he,
he jumped up the way had jumped up to me,
looked like he was putting on a show.
Yeah.
I mean that's the impression that I got.
I might be wrong,
but my impression was that he was putting on a show,
a guy who was really scared of when,
when you're really fucked up,
can you shut that off part isn't stolen cause you hear talking in the
background.
Um,
when you're really fucked up on something and you can't walk you,
you don't know how to control your body.
And that guy was like catching himself the right way.
He was like saving himself the right way every time.
To me it looked like he was way more together than he was pretending to be and
went right through that window.
He didn't pull out of it at all.
Like he knows well enough to keep his balance while he's stumbling around.
He knows to protect his bounds,
but it doesn't know to not go through a window.
I don't buy that.
And you don't buy also falls out of the top part of the window,
the divided and there's all this smashing and you know,
but it doesn't look like smashing window to me,
you know?
I mean,
he just kind of like leaning on and all of a sudden it's going through.
What is that?
That looks fake.
The window looks fake.
The fact that he would just go over it and write through it.
He wouldn't stop himself.
Come on son.
And if you noticed,
uh,
when all that was happening there was off camera a,
he must have hit a light or a lamp and did the light bulb blow up flash.
So it was really dramatic because it was like,
Ooh,
a light bulb flash.
And that right there as a,
as a looking at to me thought,
hey,
that's purposely put there to make it more dramatic and realistic looking.
Right?
Yeah,
maybe right.
Maybe it wasn't even real.
Maybe they added it to the film,
right effect really into it.
When I saw that you really,
yeah,
I ran this by it,
man.
She'll reaction.
I'm just being honest.
Was that I thought it was my first reaction was fake.
Well,
we might be,
I might be.
Might be right.
I don't know.
We might be wrong.
It might be a whole new story about it.
Yeah.
If there's not a new story like immediately because they want to have a story
like that guy falls breaks both of his fucking legs.
Dumb ask.
It's a,
you know,
it gets a fence post up his ass.
What exactly happened to Ari when he did it?
Wow,
I'm way too much of a freak out.
He stayed put though pretty much.
They kind of held them down,
but there was,
there were watching him and they were doing it for a show.
They were doing it when they were filming the naughty show.
And the worst part about that is that you know,
you're,
you're filming it and you're trying to make light of it and you're making a
comedy podcasts.
Then you ask,
you got to do psychedelics and the worst thing you could do when you're doing
psychedelics,
this being on a fucking comedy podcasts with cameras and people,
fuck,
let's do you know,
you know the studio,
it was like everybody had was packed like three people on the couch.
There was the people,
me and everything.
So
it was like past the worst place you could ever do a,
I can tell.
And he started flailing and like I thought he was not the LCD screen or breaks
hurt himself and he stood up and it was genuine.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Completely real.
Really.
But he didn't do it.
This knucklehead did.
Did he leave?
He left.
He,
no,
he freaked out and then he cuddled Sam and they was so cute.
Cause our,
he's a little face was next to Sam and it looked like
still going on.
You see it?
Look,
there's some,
what the fuck?
This is bullshit dude.
This is videos.
Totally bullshit.
They left all this extra footage and the end of it to make it look even more
real.
Right.
Could have a clever law is some a,
what's it called?
I don't think so.
Blair witch kind of style,
right?
Yeah.
I'm just,
you know,
I just,
I see all these fucking hungry kids out there trying to come up with something
that gets people to look at their shit.
And I see creativity and ingenuity and I see a video like this and I said,
well there it is manifested itself.
Good try guys.
Very talented.
It was very funny.
But I'm not buying it son.
So crazy.
Salvia trip schools.
What does it say for real?
With a bunch is oh that's how in other ways and why,
you know it's not real yet
cause they don't even save for real with the correction on the ohs.
Check this out.
She,
I don't know what's going on.
I haven't been watching it.
I just looked over but she just finally came to it looks like and then she opens
the front door and then the guy immediately comes in right when uh,
he,
she opens the door at the same time.
Like it wasn't like she opened the door.
It was like looking around like they both came to at the same time and met at
the door.
Maybe this is like the opening scene for an amazing new film and this is viral
marketing.
The monkey moon.
This isn't it.
Yeah.
This is one of the reasons why you root for the monkeys.
It's called
people are constantly evidence.
1 billion,
226.
It's fucking idiots.
This is Morgan,
Salvia head headers out windows marketing campaigns.
This.
He tried to really pump up the numbers for the planet of the apes because you've
got to realize we lose in this one.
We lose this one.
We lose this one big fucking the chimps take over.
Yeah,
I was going to be some violence scenes.
I can't wait.
I hope so.
It's in three D is that even in three D it's going to be,
everything's in three d now,
son.
Like that shit like in the three d.
Yeah,
me too.
There'll be a shot of somebody like a monkey's going to grab a guy's ear and
it's going to tear across as fake things.
Oh yes dude.
Is it supposed to be this violent?
I'm hoping I'm
putting it out there in the universe.
I have made it to kids.
Maybe.
Maybe they,
it's a monkey story.
It's gotta be at least PG 13 I would imagine a big budget movie like this.
Probably PG 13 what do you think that Captain America actually,
I think it looks decent.
It looks bad ass fucking love superhero movies doing shit though.
Did you see it there?
Ryan rounds is a bit too handsome for my taste.
Green Horn.
I'm not into watching him wander around on TV knowing that he fucked the shit
out of scarlet.
Johannson it was like kind of done with you
moving
on to greener pastures.
You,
it sucks.
A six flags made a new roller coaster and it's not even Ryan Reynolds Pussy riot
jumping.
You're jumping a condom.
You go just fucking shooting through all these pussies all throughout Hollywood.
Just fucking exhausted,
covered it
verb.
It's kind of like it turns into knew
a water right at the very end.
You get to court kind.
She comes to the end.
The last girl comes and shoots you over the top of a fucking mountain.
That dude's got a sweat himself so hard.
How could he not?
Of course you've got the craziest roll the dice ever handsome.
Well spoken people like funny,
funny,
really funny.
Good look and it's fucking nailing it.
Sun,
sweat,
sweat.
You mother fucker.
Dude apparently just usurped a Jennifer Lopez and I heard this news.
No,
just could not.
Maybe true.
Maybe not.
Maybe I heard it from somebody.
Read it on the Internet and Internet and I haven't even bothered looking at it
up,
but apparently Jennifer Lopez gotten some sort of a romantic soiree.
Ooh.
With some dude who she was dancing with.
Now all of a sudden our fucking shows become TMZ cause I need to find out if
that's true,
that Green Hornet Roller coasters and even open yet.
Can you imagine him like they spent all this money on this roller coaster and
they're like,
Oh God,
that movie was gay.
I mean bad.
And then we have to do it.
Announcing a split to sing at a wedding.
Six is that a six flags?
Ryan's going to be six flags.
It's not,
I don't even think it's so funny.
What's the other superhero one?
What's the one that stuck around?
Seth Rogen black.
Worn it.
Jennifer Lopez still fucking keeps it together.
Oh,
green horn.
Greenlanders this is why I knew this is why I needed this.
Marriage was never going to work.
Why?
What is it?
She's too hot.
She is still hot.
She's still hot.
It's Jennifer Lopez.
She's like 50 now,
right?
What is she?
How old is she now?
She's 86 years old.
She's 97 years old and she's hot as fuck.
She's younger than me.
I shouldn't be talking shit.
She's only 41 but God damn,
she's still hot as fuck,
and that dude that she's with that Mark Anthony Fella,
he's got a music looker.
He's got a mirror at home.
He knows what the fuck is up when he needs to do with belt out some God down
number one hits.
It's the only way he's going to keep around and let's be honest,
he really hasn't done that lately.
I haven't been hearing,
nobody's been screaming and yelling about how great Marc Anthony's music is.
Unless you are one of the baddest motherfuckers ever you Justin Bieber and
prince rolled up in one and you look like that.
It's going to be hard to keep a girl like Jennifer Lopez for sure.
Those are some genetic son.
Those are some I need Dick Genetics.
He I'm saying,
yeah,
he's a look at that.
Look at that girl's body.
Where's that from?
What's that?
That that body's a goddamn homing signal for a cock.
I'm Puerto Rican.
It's all good though.
A magnet for a dick.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
Puerto Rican Dix hills.
Sampson.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
Yep.
Couldn't,
she couldn't keep it together.
She uh,
she hooked up with some other dude can imagine how many,
how many guys fucking rail and smash that when she was one of the girls
Don Johnson hop arguing.
They argued for months.
Nonstop.
That makes me so sad.
Yeah.
Why argue you guys have all the money in the world.
They have a kid,
they have twins,
right?
Yeah.
What do I give a fuck when people are listening to his podcasts going,
what do you give a fuck?
Listen,
I don't,
and I blamed the weed and Oprah.
I believe him.
The weed on me as if it wasn't for the weekend.
I would not be on a,
uh,
Marc Anthony and Jennifer Lopez swit split Google run right now.
Yeah,
man.
You ever get an a Google run?
And he'd go,
what the fuck is wrong with me,
man?
Yeah.
I'm thinking about getting one of these Mac book airs.
Good,
good,
good.
Get One.
So before we,
we didn't finish this Macha Picchu thing,
man.
Oh,
I'm looking at some photos of this shit now.
Tell me you,
you,
we kept getting off track.
W you got there,
you fly to Cusco flag.
Who's Colima and you stay there.
Usually most people stay there at least like a day or two to get acclimated to,
you know,
being up that high.
Right.
And then you take a train from Cusco to what is essentially the bottom of the
mountain that Machu Picchu is on.
And then you take a bus up the hill.
He'd be very unsafe.
Bus Ride,
might I add?
Is it like one of those things with us?
There's a road and then this mountain to the righthand side.
Dude,
you're,
you're on a road that's on the side of a mountain with no guard rails or
anything in on a bus just going up,
up,
and you're just like,
we're on a mountain.
That kind of thing.
That stuff where you can look,
you can look out of your bus window and just see down.
Yeah.
Your bus driver falls asleep.
Freaks out.
Yeah,
whatever.
Had a long night,
a dog runs across the road,
he has to hit the brakes.
Drinks just does anything.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
It's not like,
oh,
how,
how wide is the road not wide.
Oh yeah.
I did the Pacific coast highway once the drive from California,
from southern California,
northern California along the coast.
It's fucking amazing.
Amazing.
While you're driving now you just like,
oh my God,
this is so incredible.
But you can't even look at it because you're glued that little skinny slice of
rock hanging over the Pacific Ocean,
by the way,
in a place where the ground moves all the time.
Yeah.
And you're driving 35 miles an hour.
You can't drive any faster.
Cause he's a fucking person in front of you.
And by the way,
when you're,
you're in a cooperative agreement with all those other fuck sticks on that road.
Yeah.
You know,
you got to know that this guy come in this way isn't just freaking out and
stomping on his gas and turning into traffic because his girlfriend left him
right now.
You gotta you gotta hope that everyone you meet is keeping it together.
Fuck that and fuck man,
it's terrifying because you don't have to take that.
Okay,
well here's a quicker route is actually to not take when I want to.
Taking that route on the ocean is just the scenic view.
So we,
I did it once with an ex girlfriend of mine.
I got a ticket going up and to going.
How long does it speed trap because they know you want to drive home.
Yeah.
I mean again,
you know,
he lives out there so it's all just people driving from San Francisco to La
along the coast.
So it's crazy speed traps.
How long does that take?
So long time.
I don't remember.
It's like somewhere around six hours.
I think it was somewhere around that.
And that's it.
If you're,
you know,
following a reasonable pace.
We actually,
I think went to Monterey,
that's where we went and then went to San Francisco later.
But it's not worth the drive.
It's a fucking cunt of a drive.
Yeah.
That takes way longer.
But the coast,
but the Machu Picchu things.
So you're on this road here on this road,
there's no guard rail and just like that where it's a skinny road on the side of
a giant mountain.
You're in the driver's hands,
like how long from the time that you land in the plane,
how long before you actually get to the top and this bus?
Well,
you land,
like I said,
you land in Cusco.
Usually I stay there a day or two.
Then take a train.
It's a couple hour train ride I want to say.
Do you stay there on purpose to normalize?
Yeah,
most people do.
Most people do.
Yeah,
because also since you already flew in to Cusco that day,
you probably usually don't feel like taking the train because the best time to
goes in the morning to get the whole day.
So you,
you stay a couple of days,
you get on a train,
you take the train ride,
then you get the bus up the hill,
and then when you arrive at the,
you arrive at,
at,
at the top and you are just a,
you know,
let's say a hundred yards or something from where the actual Machu Picchu,
the city as you're at,
you're at the receiving area and you walk over and it's,
it just blows your mind,
man.
There's nothing,
I mean there's,
there's no way to describe it.
There's a city,
an ancient city way up,
thousands of feet,
7,000 feet up in the mountains and it's elaborate.
It's precise.
There's reasons for the placement of things.
The Sun hits certain parts of it,
certain ways,
and you're just like,
we're,
we're way up.
You know,
like you're looking down from the top of a mountain in a city and there it was
inhabited and fully functioning and you know,
it's just,
like I said,
the size of the place,
of the magnitude of it all,
it blows your mind.
It's,
there's nothing like event.
How long were you up there for?
I would spend,
you know,
hours like,
uh,
you arrive in the morning,
let's say you're there by like a guide or something like that takes you yeah.
And they,
and they have so much information.
Blows your mind.
Like how old did they say it is?
Ah,
I'm trying to remember.
I haven't been there in a while now,
but I want to say that they said well because it's documented when the Spanish
went there and killed like thousands of them with like a hundred guys,
you know,
because uh,
they came with disease and weapon and they just wiped them out.
I was in Hawaii last week and uh,
we were reading about,
um,
when,
when white people first came to Hawaii,
it killed off one fifth of the Hawaiian population.
Damn.
Cause that's these people.
One fifth.
Yeah.
Can you imagine how much you would fucking hate white people if they showed up
and your daughter died from measles because these creeps brought over some
creepy fucking disease.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
I mean,
it,
it's,
well that's well documented.
We could look that up.
It's,
I want to say they,
it was like thousands to one that they killed them.
And that was in the 15.
I want to say 15,
13 or 15 to 60.
Something like that.
Just make some shit up bro.
No one's going to go and look it up.
Fucking,
I was going to Google it.
Yes.
They,
I'm not an expert.
So,
um,
when you go up there,
so they give you some sort of a,
an estimation of when it was created,
did they tell you who the people were or why they built it?
They give you,
it's all theories.
There's,
it's never been discovered.
And they tell you that their theories because that you,
there's no record to prove that this was in fact the way they did it.
But like,
so was it one thing sorta when they,
they're just sort of found it.
Yeah.
It was,
it was discovered in the early 19 hundreds by like an explorer and American
explorer,
I think,
kind a British and he,
uh,
you know,
it had,
it was overgrown,
like weeds and grass and everything had to grown.
And then,
yeah.
Can you imagine you're on a hike and then they take you to see this and you're
like,
what the fuck man,
but a sudden you just find some lost city,
the lost city man from thousands of years ago where yield loss.
I wish I could remember what the,
uh,
the chariots of the gods slash Graham Hancock crew thinks,
about this place because I think there's some,
there is some sort of speculation that it was at the side of water at one point
in time.
Really?
Yeah.
That you know,
that the topography of the earth was so radically different when this thing was
created that it's so many thousands of years old that there was actually a water
up there with this guy wants to do is as John Anthony West Guy,
he wants to push back the idea of civilization like more like more than 10,000
BC.
He wants to go like way back,
even like 30,000 BC and he thinks that theirs is sort of a hieroglyphs that
represent that.
But for whatever reasons,
Egyptian scholars of refuse to look at those hieroglyphs and they believe that
it's all fiction after a certain point and it's just a fiction and fable.
When he's saying,
well,
why would you think that?
Because there's all this other evidence that we know is real.
It's also in the hieroglyphs.
Why wouldn't,
why would we assume that at one point in time they were just liars,
you know?
Yeah.
So it's Kinda,
did you fuck this new one up again?
It's still broken.
We got to number one though.
I know it never really,
the new one doesn't work either.
Now God damn it son.
Anyway,
those guys are right.
And it was like 30,000 years ago or whatever the hell it was where there was a
civilization up here and there was an ocean up there or river or whatever the
hell it was.
Is it,
and it's not near Ocean,
right?
No,
I mean,
you know,
no,
not,
I would have to be some giant lake or something out there,
but they have one of their theories is that they used water to lay those rocks
and to make them to shape them like through some extremely,
you know,
I dunno.
Intricate formula that water,
cause you know like water hits,
rocks and shapes them over time.
Right.
To beat them down to sand.
They have a theory that that water was used to make rocks like this fit into
each other.
But there's some elaborate system that you,
you hear about it and you go like,
yeah,
I don't fucking know man.
That's pretty,
the sheer size of them is what's really mind boggling.
It really has been there.
The eight,
nine feet tall and they're curved and they,
and they fit into other curved garage and thousands of thousand tons.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know thousands of times.
What's the biggest one?
I should know this.
We should know that we're talking shit,
but they,
there are,
there are enormous stones up there.
Whatever the fuck it is.
I highly recommend a trip there.
You're making me want to go.
I really it so far.
When you land in the morning at this one place,
before you,
before you get in the bus and all the jazz,
when you land in the morning,
do they give you like,
like a survival pack or anything?
These things,
here's water.
You're at high altitude.
Well when you land in Cusco,
yeah.
Everyone,
like if you're never been there like hotels will,
we'll give you tea.
They'll give you,
you know,
trying to keep telling you to hydrate.
Yeah.
Everybody,
I mean it's,
you know,
peruse,
considered a third world,
but like it's,
it's actually really developed now.
Yeah,
this is,
yeah.
And this is such a international destination that like everything is like
modern,
you know,
like as far as getting you there.
And I mean the last time I went was 10 years ago and you know,
it was still pretty much,
but there's a hotel at the location if you want to stay over night,
there's a hotel right there.
So like not like,
you know,
not within the city of Machu Picchu,
but right.
Kind of not far from it.
So you can stay in the hotel like it's very not ghost in the middle of the
night.
It's sword fights and thousands years ago really like affects you.
It affects you really.
Yeah.
Like you,
you stay in there and you take it in.
You're looking at it like you're looking at the sky and the mountains and you're
like,
what?
Like how is this possible?
Cause it,
it,
it blows your mind.
And in terms of like most things that you look at,
there's so many like explanations and answers for,
and this is something where they're really,
you really don't have one.
Like you can't,
you can't have somebody to tell you this is exactly what this was.
So it then why did he say he can't just because it's just too nutty,
too big because,
and because there's no proof that,
that it was used for this and it was built this way.
They're all theories,
theories on why this was done.
And so that then opens your mind up to like,
really what are possibilities?
I think,
you know,
like what are possibilities in the world?
Like,
you know,
what are the possibilities that you got from,
from being there looking at that,
just that,
that um,
it was underwater and mermaids built it.
Uh,
I just got that it was something that,
uh,
you know,
that it's greater than what my mind can conceive of a,
it makes you feel like really small,
you know,
in,
in a lot of terms like just by the scope of it.
And like if,
if this was done by some intricate like Levy and pulling system with water like
men,
how little do I know?
Like how,
how,
how little have I taken in that people that were in an ancient civilization
built a city up like my,
like,
am I have the lowest Iq level possible because this is,
I,
you know,
you could explain it to me 20 times.
I'd be like,
what?
I don't understand what you're saying right now.
Like really like,
you know,
you go,
that's,
and then also you think about,
I think you think about like spiritual thing.
Like you definitely feel something like,
you know,
you think about God and possibilities of Gods and stuff mean these people all
worshiped.
Um,
I believe the sun and other gods,
you know,
and cause did so,
they were just doing this for what they believed was God,
you know,
worshiping him or they sacrificed and could sacrificed.
Do you know they would kill their own offer him up.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
It's pretty amazing,
man.
I wonder what made them build those things.
So when,
when,
what I would think as far as it being very spiritual to be there and the terms
of what I mean by spiritual is that if a spirit was real and if there is some
sort of an energy that's inside of a life form,
that energy like leaves and stays in that space once the person's gone.
When you go to a place like a Machu Picchu,
when you think about all of the thousands of years of history and all the people
that have died,
all the people that died in that area and what,
what,
you know how long ago it was like if there was ever any feeling you could get of
like the spirit of a place,
it would have to be some sort of an really,
really ancient place.
You know,
a,
a place along those lines like standing,
like we're Troy is walking around the coliseum and the touching the Parthenon,
like shit like that.
Like can you go to like really,
really ancient places like that?
That's,
I mean,
I know it's a different term when you say like spiritual,
but it's kind of like this gotta be like a certain energy to those places.
If you really believe in that,
if you really believe that human energy stays in the area when the,
when the person is,
is,
is killed,
which people believe when they believe that houses are haunted,
you know,
I know a lot of people that you tell them,
hey,
you want to buy Jon Benet Ramsey house?
It's like,
go get the fuck outta here.
Like I'll do,
it's the best house ever.
It's beautiful.
It's only like half what it would be worth.
It wasn't Jon Benet Ramsey still still still be like,
fuck that.
I'm not living in that house.
Why?
Because they think that there might be some energy in that house.
There's something leftover.
Yeah.
They,
um,
uh,
and I think that's almost even a better way of like describing what it is you
get.
Like you feel something when you're in that presence,
like that type of greatness,
which is that I think you feel like a boost.
You know what I mean?
Like,
yeah.
Like some feeling that you're,
when you're there you can't,
you,
you cannot unless you're a total sociopath.
Walk into Matsu Pete Machu Picchu and just be like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Cool.
All right,
well you guys went,
you able to grab lunch like it's,
it's too amazing to captivating,
like inspiring to just be like seen it.
It's,
it's amazing.
Yeah.
I would love to go to a place where I knew there was like Roman battles just to
walk on the ground.
Yeah.
Like where the coliseum is.
They let you on the ground there in the coliseum they liked you actually walk
onto the holder in the middle.
Yeah.
You don't get to walk all throughout it.
They have like there's areas that you can through.
Yeah.
It's like a path through the whole thing.
If I,
if I,
if I remember dude eat a pot Brownie and stay in the middle of the coliseum and
think of how crazy that shit is.
Could you imagine if you were blitzkrieg and one of those Joey Diaz Banana bread
specials that he gets from that Russian place and you went to the fucking Roman
Colosseum and you stood there in the middle of that.
That'd be awesome.
Dude.
Can I read you this about,
I looked up this thing.
Okay.
In,
um,
in 1531,
the Spanish expedition led by a Fransisco be saddle.
The,
the guy that just likes discovered Peru in for Spain,
let's say.
Right.
Right now that was the Spanish guy that came over.
He had 180 men and 37 horses.
We're on a quest to conquer the Incan Empire,
Hispanic,
Spanish advanced to the south,
um,
after receiving reinforcements.
Um,
and then what they marched toward it force a with a force of 106 foot soldiers
and 62 horsemen and they went on to beat out the wallpaper,
the Incan guy and I believe his 80,000 man army.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Cause they had guns and disease.
Their disease killed
a huge holy shit.
So a couple hundred bad motherfuckers from Spain just dominated that whole
place.
Yup.
And he captured a,
he captured the top dog,
the Spanish did it captured at the Wada and they,
uh,
they offered,
he offered to fill a large room.
They tell you this like when you're there,
but 22 feet long,
17 feet wide.
And I hate height of eight feet with gold and twice with silver within two
months.
So to fill up rooms,
which is gold and silver and the Spanish,
uh,
agreed to the terms.
Um,
got the gold and silver and then killed him.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
Gangster style.
Right.
God Damn.
And I'm cute.
Imagine if you were forced to live like back then,
can you imagine if you are on the fucking shores of Peru or the ground in Peru
and you saw the Spaniards rolling over the hill and horses and shit shooting at
you?
Yeah.
They just decided they were just going to take over mother fucker.
Could you imagine how much that would suck?
Yeah,
they uh,
uh,
they were going,
he was,
they sentenced him,
they like did a,
like a formal,
like you're on trial,
you're guilty,
we're going to kill you now.
And then they sentenced him to die by burning and then they,
uh,
they gave in accordance with his request because he agreed to be baptized then
a,
they strangled them instead.
Oh my God.
Wow.
He agreed to be baptized and then they strangled him instead of burning them
alive.
Yeah.
That was the compromise.
Holy Shit.
They got one more compromise out of them before they killed them.
Crazy.
Made we get baptized.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
Dude.
People back then rocked it in an entirely different way.
You know,
back then you really could be like a Michelle Bachmann and control the world.
Yeah.
You know,
it was,
there was no internet videos from 1999 with you talking about the apocalypse and
doom and absolutely man,
the fucking,
could you imagine if you could get inside the head of any sort of a dictator
from that time period?
Any sort of,
uh,
a king or,
you know,
just,
just to get it,
it's like,
see how they were running shit back in like 1492 when Columbus took off.
They were,
you know,
they were,
they,
people forget like Spain.
That was,
that was gangster country.
Yeah,
they have,
we have,
uh,
there are however many people like gotta be like close to 700 million or 800
million people that speak a language from like 3000 miles away.
Cause they fucking ran shit man.
They swung their dicks around.
Hey,
there's a hundred of us,
they're going to kill you.
80,000.
Yeah.
All gangster shit now.
And it's like if they were a hundred dudes without a country,
they would just be pirates.
Yeah.
No one would take them seriously.
They'd be a band of pirates and Ruffins but instead,
history actually looks upon it as,
you know,
almost like a qualified act.
Like,
well,
you know,
they were Spain attacked this,
instead of,
you know,
like,
black beard and his gang of thugs tried to take over at North Carolina,
you know,
instead of that,
it's,
it's not the whole country.
So it's qualified as thuggish when it's super thuggish,
it's totally thuggish.
It's the most gangster shit ever.
100 dudes take over the fucking whole country.
Unbelievable man.
Shit.
That's insane,
man.
That's hard to believe.
They have rapid fire guns back then or was it a muscle?
No,
no,
they did it with Moscow.
He took over with muskets.
How stressful that would be like somebody who's like running right towards you
and you're just trying to fucking fill your muscles.
It's also the case though that when the Spaniards came,
there was a lot of confusion.
They thought the Spaniards were gods and so they'll let them in.
Yeah.
I think the Spanish took off,
took over and started killing people.
I think of Cortez,
right?
It might be Cortez.
Is that Cortez?
My fucking,
my mind history is completely limited.
My Aztec history,
all I know is the cool shit.
Like can't Kukula [inaudible] was the snake with the fucking feathers bro.
Like I know shit like that.
Well that's all Quadel.
I know they had a lot of them hadn't seen horses so they thought they were like,
I saw horses and they were like,
what the fuck?
That's why didn't they think that the Spaniards on horses were initially gods?
Yeah,
I think they thought they were one being too,
cause they came off and they're like,
that thing has got four legs.
Yeah.
I think there was,
there was a lot of,
a lot of confusion in the beginning and they actually gave them a lot of money
and like let them deep in and then they eventually realized,
but if it was too late,
the demonic gods,
they were just men that rode around and fucking horses.
Unbelievable man.
That's how bad people had it back then.
Yeah.
Tenzing that does not that long ago.
And they would do shit like tell them like,
your whole worship shit is bullshit.
Yeah.
It's Catholic.
Like you're Catholic or you're dead and the car.
All right.
Whatever the thing they'd done for like all the only thing they knew,
which was probably,
you know,
son or are like stars.
These guys were like,
that's not what,
it's Hawaii too,
man.
Yeah.
No.
So I said that with the correct terminology or what's the word?
An NCAA.
[inaudible] Hawaii.
Um,
they,
they had a mercenaries are missionaries,
same thing.
Missionaries.
They're mercenaries for God.
That's all it is.
Mercenaries came to Hawaii in the 18 hundreds and converted them into
Christianity.
And uh,
like in the 18 hundreds,
they had their first Christian King,
you know?
Yeah.
And they're like,
mmm.
Yeah.
Hawaii.
Hawaii's a crazy situation,
man.
Did you swim with dolphins when you're there last?
No,
there was no dolphins.
I didn't see any dolphins,
but I did it a few times ago.
Not,
not this time,
but the last time in alumni.
So another one of the islands and they're there.
You can swim with the dolphins.
The,
the most,
the triplets experience that I ever had was in a boat with the dolphins.
Dolphins will follow the boats and the play with you and jump around next to
you.
Yeah.
It's amazing that that's five hours away by plane,
yet it's America.
Yeah.
And if we can't wrap our head around how big that is,
that's literally,
if you took off from Burbank and the whole country was the ocean,
the whole country,
every state along the way.
You look at Ohio,
it's all ocean.
And then you land in New Jersey and as the shore,
that's how fucking far away Hawaii,
Hawaii is over the ocean and yet it's still considered America.
That really is,
you forget that.
That's colonization,
right?
That's what that is.
That's gangster shit is what that is.
Old School gangster shit.
He'll Hawaii was taken over and the 1890s by businessmen.
Yeah.
At least that's what it said when I was reading there.
That thing,
there just were some fucking people trying to keep on keeping on out there in
the middle of the ocean,
living on a volcano.
You know Spain,
Spain's still has the Canary Islands that's off the west coast to Africa and
they're like,
that's how I should,
we're lucky that Hawaii is five hours away in a plane because that is the best
spot ever.
If that,
if that was like you could drive there and people would ruin that in a week
cause you could drive it to Hawaii.
They made a bridge to Hawaii.
It would be backed up with cars every day forever and Hawaii be covered in dirt
and,
and fucking plastic bags and cigarette butts.
It'd be jacked within no time.
Yeah.
It's so beautiful.
It's a fact that you have to fly over there.
She can't bring too much shit with you.
You can't keep your shit there unless you live there.
And if you live there,
they give you a shit if you're a fucking litter bug Yukon living on,
yeah,
like you walk along the beach,
the beaches are clean man there,
there've actually fucking clean like the sea,
very little trash on the beach.
And if that was the same beach and the east coast,
it would just be everywhere you looked.
It'd be a can or a bottle or a fucking a tampon or a syringe.
Like every where you go this
trash,
they can't clean it up enough.
And then it's in the water as well because you know,
the water's coming from all the way the fuck up to Maine and everything along
down the way.
All down the east coast.
It's all just fucking of cities and shit and people,
you know,
empty in there,
fucking toilet into the water.
So by the time it gets to where you are,
it's,
you know,
it's disgusting.
Half of them are disgusting and comparison.
Hawaii just pristine man.
Beautiful.
Couldn't deal with living there though.
No.
Yeah,
I was thinking there.
I went to a Luau.
It's pretty bad ass covering up more interesting.
Sure.
Row is that Lou Ella is like a party,
right?
Yeah.
It's like a party.
They cook a pig under the ground.
The pig was delicious.
And uh,
the dude who was one of the Hawaiian dance or dudes was a,
uh,
MMA fan.
He's hooked me up and he gave me a piece of the cheek that's supposed to be the
best part of the pig.
The butt cheek or the face cheek.
The face cheek.
Not the butt cheek doing,
how dare you.
Well,
you do eat the skin.
They give you a crispy skin.
They cook the scans.
It's really good.
It's good.
Yeah.
Slow,
slow cook,
pig,
slow cook pig.
It's pretty fucking spectacular.
It's a,
it's amazing stuff.
Hmm.
Um,
um,
but their music is whack.
You have to sit through their music,
you know,
and all,
all,
all I was thinking was,
I mean it's a beautiful culture there.
They're amazing people.
Especially,
let's be honest,
especially when you're going to a resort and you're spending money where they
have to be nice to you.
You know what I'm saying?
But even outside of that,
like in Maui,
people are very nice.
They're just friendly.
If you're not,
like,
whenever I hear people say things like,
Oh Hawaii,
I just don't like white people.
They don't like people.
Well,
why not?
Is it because so many white people are cunts?
Yeah.
Is that possibly what it is?
My experience there is that they've always been super nice there.
They're just really genuinely nice people.
But so many people are Douche bags and you're a Douche bag.
You coming from another country basically to them and you're littering and
you're acting like an asshole.
And of course they're going to want to kick your ass.
Of course.
You know?
So there's this certain amount of Douche bags,
I'm sure that live in Hawaii,
but for the most part it's,
it's a really nice,
but that music bro,
that Lou AllMusic goal,
there was a song that they sang about a woman selling papayas and a red and
green bananas and that was the whole fucking song she's sending her Papaya has
and then green when uh,
uh,
and that's the song and I'm going fucking crazy.
I'm going crazy because I just got there from the gym too.
I worked out,
they have a nice gym there at the hotel,
so I kinda know full fucking four days of power training their son.
I worked out hard there so it felt good,
which kept me together.
But the whole time I was a,
in the gym,
I was listening to some old school,
Leonard Skinner,
I got like really into Leonard Skinner this week.
Yeah,
they got some fucking jams do heroin shit.
Oh God.
It was just,
I just got into the whole idea of these dirty white guys from Florida,
you know,
drinking and sing in and it's just,
it's a fucking good vibe.
Some of their songs are fucking great man,
free birds kind of a song
and there's parts that are not that fun,
but when they go and they just start getting low that I can't change
free
bird.
Hey Pam,
Pam,
dude.
When you left in and that fucking shit comes on,
you're like,
you just want to fucking fire up some extra sets.
So I heard that I had just heard Freebird I had just heard they know the ballot
of is low.
I just heard,
you know,
I just heard all the cool shit.
They call me the breeze.
It's like beer-drinking guys that like fucking rock and roll and I'm sitting
there and I pop up restroom.
Of course I want a full Hawaii experience.
I'm sitting here at this Luau,
beg to the Gills,
trying to keep an eye on the kids drinking,
drinking,
Pina Coladas,
listening to some whack ass music.
And I'm like,
and while I'm sitting there,
I'm having a great ass time in Hawaii.
The weather,
it's beautiful,
it's paradise.
I'm thinking,
God damn,
how awesome would it be if they just said,
ladies and gentleman,
please welcome letter together.
And the Hawaiian guys step aside and somehow another body van sat is still alive
and they fucking start jamming.
Leonard scattered out there on the beach.
I would pay $100,000 for that shit.
All right.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean fucking then it would be an amazing vacation.
Yeah,
you're making me listening to a couple of C's
and her and been greeting,
but none other other cultures.
I don't know why some music is so,
so bad,
like vicious,
brutal lot of like you go to like,
you know,
you look at research like eastern European countries and they're fucking music.
Jazz music is like,
what the fuck?
Yeah,
it totally is Borat shit and so good.
And they all are really like that and like,
and it's some guy with some creepy fucking mustache.
He was like,
no and none of it really sounds like it has a melody or rhythm and,
and they're going crazy.
Like that's the best song ever.
That's the song that the goat doesn't drink out of the founder cause that's
where you live.
And you're like,
what the,
what is it the,
what's up?
What's up with Mexican music?
Same kind of thing,
right?
Like every single song sounds like an ice cream truck going down the street.
I mean it's like there is a,
there's a type of,
uh,
the,
the Mariachi music,
you know,
the good Mariachi music with good trumpets.
Like when you hear like Oscar de la Hoya stepping into the,
into the ring,
when he's walking down the aisle,
step into the ring,
he brings with him a bad ass Mariachi bands.
These mother fuckers are on top of shit
and they're doing that shit.
Man.
These guys are bad ass to watch.
Like they're,
they're,
they're experts.
They're doing the real shit.
You know,
there's some bullshit down there because wack ass Mariachi,
you realize some white cast stand up.
What a big culture is in Mexico,
uh,
that cowboys.
I right,
like,
you know,
cowboy.
We were,
and we have a country music,
a lot of that shit.
You're hearing that you're like,
what is that?
That's their country music.
Right.
That's why you're like this fucking shit.
Terrible man.
They do have regular music.
Only music I've ever heard.
I was listening to a rap station that was in Mexico and there was also one
station that we went on where we were allowed to swear because their station,
their tower was actually located in Mexico and even though we were in San Diego,
they were a Mexican station and so we were allowed to swear on the air.
It was like,
that is fucking crazy.
He goes,
don't do it too much,
but you can swear a little.
Right.
Really?
Yeah.
That is cool.
It was weird.
Yeah,
it's cool,
but look at this fucking thing we're doing right now.
We don't have to worry about any of that bullshit.
We want to say fucking radio seems so obsolete now,
and I do radio and I love doing it.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean it's,
it's always nice and Kevin and being are my favorite as far as people that are
like still on radio.
They're like my favorite show to come in because it's in another way and I can
do it all the time,
but God,
I always have to watch what I'm saying.
I always have to wonder if I could say this or say that.
Like,
I,
you know,
you gotta be careful.
Yeah.
I've had some really bad radio experiences lately.
Really just like shit where you're like,
man,
can you fucking,
can you do a little bit like to add to this?
Like,
what do you mean?
Like they'll go,
I've had one where like,
I get there and they're like,
just the green rooms over there.
We'll come get you.
And you're like,
all right,
you just sit down and get the green room.
And then the guy comes and he's like,
Hey,
so,
uh,
how you doing?
Um,
you'll be on the next segment.
Like,
we don't really do interviews or anything.
It's like,
just,
you know,
be funny.
And I'd be like,
what?
And they're like,
it's all on you,
man.
Just be funny and I'm like,
just be funny.
Like we're just going to read.
What do you mean you want to start doing jokes?
They're like,
just your chance to do whatever you want to do.
I'm like,
well,
can we just like talk?
Do you want us to ask you something specifically?
I'm like,
well,
can we can't like have like a regular,
like you don't want to like just make it an organic conversation.
Yeah.
Like can we just do that?
We don't really do that here.
Yeah.
You know,
they tried.
Mami did not too down in the Bob and Tom show.
Some guy came in,
Bob and Tom were cool as fuck those guys.
They were very cool guys.
Yeah.
Once I actually got in to meet them,
but before I got to meet them,
there was some dude that was like,
give me the stink eye.
And he goes,
well,
what specifically do you want them to talk to you about?
And I go Eggo due to anything.
I go,
I'm low maintenance.
Just let's just talk.
Let's have a good time.
Well they would,
they need things to lead you into,
I call it,
dude,
I can't do that.
I'm not,
yeah.
I'm not going to tell you that I'm going to talk about this or I'm going to talk
about that.
It's going to,
that's going to sound gross.
No,
let's just sit down.
We're going to have some fun.
Don't worry about it.
And he came to the stink eye like I was unprofessional.
Do you know that this is the Bob and Tom Show?
Billy and Bob and Tom show is a fucking huge show.
Yeah,
it's huge.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
syndicated all across the country.
They probably have millions of listeners.
They got a lot of fucking listeners.
They help.
They help a lot of comedians.
Totally there.
I've been done that show a number of times and they're always awesome.
They're great guys.
Dude was giving me the stink eye,
but you know,
in his defense it's probably what he's supposed to do,
you know,
that's his fucking job and I'm ruining it.
You know,
like I'm some hot shots.
It's going to come in here and I had to slink Dick.
I had another one who,
uh,
I did call in and the,
the guy's like,
obviously you're going to be on a minute.
Just like,
you know,
you got it.
You got a couple of jokes ready to go.
I was like,
I guess,
and then he's like,
all right.
So then they pushed me on.
The guy's like,
hey,
you're going to be at the club.
It's awesome.
Everybody go see him.
All right man.
Now before you do your thing,
we're gonna have you do your thing right here.
And I'm like,
Nah,
I'm just going to start going.
Oh my God,
that's so gross.
And then we just talk from it and he's like,
just go right into Ralphie May's act.
I'll just go right into Ralph.
He's,
I can tell him that he did it to say,
Ralphie,
man,
I just,
I just wasn't ready to do your act.
I just shorten that on you don't even do it yourself.
Make it an inside joke.
Yeah.
I should write somebody else's material,
Tom.
Yeah.
Do on purpose.
Like tell like having an agreement with someone.
Listen if I'm ever in a bad situation and they want me to do my own material,
I'm going to do it very badly,
but I'm gonna do your stuff.
Do it.
Yeah.
Okay.
And you make a deal.
Yeah.
Cause otherwise it's like what it's supposed to be.
Go ahead and tell us what you,
what you think it's funny these days,
man.
Yeah.
Did it and you're like,
ah,
I had a conversation with,
I'm an out,
I don't give a fuck.
Cheech from Cheech and Chong at a party once and he's like,
what are you talking about on stage?
I go all,
you know,
whatever.
Whatever I think is interesting.
You know,
whatever was going on in my life,
you know what I mean?
What are you talking about now?
Like tell me some of your material.
I go,
what?
What?
This is what I said to him.
What'd you just say?
Come on man.
Fuck out of here.
I'm not telling you my material.
This is what I,
that's gross.
Yeah,
it is gross.
You won't,
you know,
if you ever want to come to a show and,
well the thing is too like kind of I,
he kept going to like,
so what are you,
come on,
tell me what you're talking about.
This is really what it comes down to to like,
it's like all you have to do,
if you have a comment,
if you're a radio station or whatever it a Dj is,
just have the minimum amount,
like feign interest in who's in front of you,
like just a little bit and you can get a conversation going that there's going
to be interesting and funny.
And like usually if it's somebody famous,
like if you,
they go,
it's already in their head.
So they'll be like,
I love news radio or you sweat though.
So they'll ask you like,
what about this?
And they can get something going.
But if they don't know who you are,
they don't recognize you.
They sometimes,
some,
not all of them,
but some of them will literally just be like,
so what's up?
And like,
you're on the air and you're like,
uh,
flew in what?
I'm tired.
And they're like,
do you have any?
Like you want to get into your shit and you're like,
just really like,
I'm just going to fucking dance around right now.
Maybe it's people that just don't understand stand up,
I guess.
You know?
I just,
it always makes it like this is like weird and then you leave it.
Like that was fun.
That wasn't a promotion for the show.
That was just awkwardness.
Yeah.
That was really awkward and painful and I don't want anything to do with that.
Again,
I don't think a lot of those guys that are doing radio want to be doing it that
way either.
It was a lot of them that are stuck with a real format.
They have to follow up.
Yeah.
That's a bitch dude.
When you're hanging around with people and you know their shit,
they can't talk about any more breaks they have to hit and you know.
Yeah.
But that just sounds like people just suck at radio.
They do.
Yeah.
Some of them do.
You know,
some of them just don't like,
I think he would just look up one thing on somebody can be like,
what's up with this dude?
Well I think a lot of people,
um,
are not that interesting.
Yeah.
And that's the reality of it.
They shouldn't really be Djs,
but they've worked hard at it and they've pushed themselves into a situation
where there,
you know,
on TV all the or on the radio rather all the time.
We actually have a little bit of a following and then they get a little bit of
an ego behind it and they think they're special.
Yeah.
I would like to buy a book of just like a thousand people doing their stinkeye
like different versions of their stinkeye cause everyone is a little bit
different.
It would have to be a legit stinkeye though.
Let me see your state guy.
I don't know.
You'd have to say something stupid again.
I'll give it to you.
How about that?
Ready?
I shaved my boss the other day and I have a mole on,
I forgot about it and I cut it off.
Is that okay?
Yeah,
you should.
Probably you'd be okay.
Okay.
Melissa can be cut off right,
but your,
your balls are probably like a fucking water balloon and that's going to be a
whole,
we're all your loads going to leak out of next time.
Next time you come it's going to be like dust.
It's one of those big weird ones that some people have under their eyes.
Put a bandaid on that bitch.
Don't worry about it.
If it starts to swell up and hurt,
go to a doctor.
Okay.
Clean it off.
It was just,
I just have the one,
it was like one of the ones that stick out a little like that's called a wart.
No,
no,
no.
It's a mall.
It's a lot of comparisons of that little baby.
Yeah.
You might want to get it free.
One in five round,
whatever dog.
Get that shit.
[inaudible] now it is.
Most of it is gone or the whole thing.
I cut the whole thing off man.
It hurt like crazy.
Seems kind of stupid.
Did you like half?
We cut it off and figure,
well,
now that I'm here and why don't I just pick at it until it looks like
symmetrical.
Is it Gillette sensor
senses from Callan who,
yeah,
he gave me a whole trunk full.
Did he really know?
Is Kay Callan is doing to Gillette sensor?
I know it's all over fucking TV.
That little Esther and the bankers.
How accounts a Gillette sensor commercials.
It's just commercial or like
a coast.
Oh really?
Yeah.
He's such a talented guy.
I'm always confused as to why that guy is not huge.
As long as I've known him,
I'm like,
someone's going to be one day where someone's going to figure out that Brian
Collins,
one of the funniest people on the planet,
boom.
Explode.
It's going to be,
I'm not huge movies and yeah.
Well he is.
And some of these little right little parts,
but yeah,
that guy is so fucking funny.
He's one of the funniest people I've ever met in my life.
Yeah,
he's really fucking funny,
man.
He does.
Uh,
he's thinking about doing a podcast.
He's a on the,
on the cusp right now.
There's any,
Brian,
did you talk to them about it?
Uh,
no.
I've never talked to him about it.
He's eventually going to do it.
I know.
He goes,
he's perfect for it.
He's got a a mountain of information.
So I've said not all of it.
Correct.
But that's all right.
Who does fascinating.
It will own up to it though.
It's like,
Oh yeah,
I fucked up about that one.
Like you know,
I'll call them on the phone.
The,
I said,
Yo,
I got a lot of Twitter is about some shit you said.
Yeah.
I fucked up a few of them.
Oh,
but full disclosure,
I might've fucked up tons of information with the Machu Picchu.
Sure.
So don't email me.
Don't tell me how wrong I was.
I been up there.
You've been up there twice.
Three times.
If you've ever been to any of the mine sites,
like teaching Eatsa or no pullover.
I've only been at Chichen Eatsa,
but that
was,
I was enough.
That was enough to freak me the fuck out.
I did.
Right.
What did you think when you first saw that?
Well,
I've been a huge fan of uh,
you know,
the,
the Mayan culture and how bizarre they were and how their writing was in this
weird sort of hieroglyphs images that represented,
I mean,
uh,
so I had,
I'd really gotten into it.
I read a lot of books about it before I ever went down there.
And then once I went down there I was like,
this is so incredible.
You know,
it's,
it's just hard to believe that these people from,
you know,
x amount of thousands of years ago created this and then it's still here.
But the thing that really sealed it for me was I got a guy who is a local
professor who was one of the guides and you paid him.
I paid him like whatever it was,
I gave him like double what he was supposed to make cause he was super cool and
he takes me on this tour,
a personal one on one tour and we go to all these different spots and it
explains what they created this for and what is designed for.
And he took me to this one spot.
He's like,
this is the place where they would do the list,
ceramic acid that they would take from all these plants.
And this was like,
well they would have psychedelic rituals and they probably mushrooms.
He's telling me about all these different things they did like and that's when
the whole mind thing had pieced together from me.
Cause I had just started doing mushrooms.
I just had like a couple of trips before I'd ever went there.
So then when I went there and I saw that these people were fucking trippers,
I'm like,
oh well that,
that explains so much.
I was wondering why would anybody build these crazy geometric patterns,
that mirror of the cosmos and he's incredible elaborate stone structures.
Like what was going on?
Oh,
they were tripping their balls off.
Do they tell you that too?
Like he explained it.
He did.
The,
the,
the professor did.
Yeah,
he went into depth about it because I told him that something I was really
interested in and I said,
I'm,
I'm always fascinated by the,
uh,
the different ways in ancient culture is altered this state of consciousness,
whether it was alcohol or you know,
the pod for the Indians or whatever.
And so he also had a lot of knowledge about that particular area.
So he talked to me in depth about what they believe happened and where this is
what they were used for rituals.
And it's certain the symbols,
uh,
indicate that they use certain different psychedelic plants and mushrooms.
Fucking of course that's what happened.
I mean,
you know,
they tripped balls,
they had some crazy ideas and then it'll get a little out of hand.
They always get out of hand,
man,
as basically those South American fucking culture is,
it's too hot down there,
dude.
People get wacky,
you know,
start slicing people over a fucking don't drink enough water and next thing you
know,
you're making a human sacrifice.
Yeah.
That shits crazy.
Right.
Human sacrifice.
He did a lot of it ritually.
Yeah.
You know,
there's speculation about that game that they played,
you know,
that football game,
which they believed at one point in time they played with human heads.
They don't necessarily believe that anymore.
They believe they may have played some games with human heads,
but they believe that the winners of the game were the ones who got sacrificed.
Really?
Yeah.
So they don't know.
I mean,
there's some speculation and we tried to lose as much as possible at least.
there's,
uh,
an amazing National Geographic special on decoding Maya.
I think it's actually called that decoding my,
about how hard it's been to decode their language and trying to figure out what
the fuck,
you know,
these guys were talking about.
It's so complex,
but you know,
just that alone,
you know,
it's all their structures.
They left behind the,
you know,
the amazing sophistication of their culture and yet they are still killing
people and sacrificing and mother and may be killing the winners.
Yeah.
You know,
the quiet why it's what were you doing?
You're the best man.
What were they doing?
W but the way that they were just,
they were just fucking trip and balls hardcore all the time.
That's why I think it was almost like that is what would happen.
What would happen to the society if you were just fucking tripping your balls
out all the time.
Well you would make these incredible pyramids and you would keep making them
doper and doper like Cheech and pizza and she needs is amazing man.
It's just incredible.
One structure after another and in mind blowing shit and then he would start
playing football with human heads and you know,
fucking,
you would just go deep and you would want to kill people because you would know
that they would go to the next place,
the next place.
It'd be amazing cause you already been there cause you're tripping balls.
So like you're tripping balls while you're cutting.
Someone's beating heart out and you're watching them as you're tripping your
balls off,
you're watching them transfer into the next dimension.
Yeah,
come on.
Yeah.
Too much mushrooms.
That's what keeps you awake at night.
That's ridiculous.
But look,
man,
if you look at all these different things that are here,
these,
the Cheecha needs says though,
you know,
the,
um,
uh,
go Beckley,
Tapley and in Turkey,
all these different things that are here that show that there's been all these
different ancient,
ancient civilizations that existed for so long.
I,
I wonder how many of them were inspired by drugs.
I wonder how many of her were inspired by some dude who picked something up,
ate it,
and had his fucking crazy freaky idea.
Here's what we gotta do.
Yeah.
We're building a city up here in the mountains.
We probably lost contact with all that shit and things are nice and easy now.
So we don't need psychedelic drugs to try to figure out the world anymore.
At least we don't think we do.
That's probably what the fuck is going on.
That's probably why this world's falling apart.
If we could write it somehow,
that would be the way you saw a massive mushroom day.
Do you know how much a mushroom day would do for this world?
A national,
national mushroom day would change America forever.
Forever.
When we just had one day,
if we had a national mushroom day where they opened up places where people could
buy mushrooms and they had medical staff waiting 24 hours a day for people who
are freaking out and you know,
you signed up and you went into these,
you know,
fucking bunk rooms and everyone took it together and everyone was cool.
They had security around a lot of people that weren't high.
That's the whole thing you want to know,
right?
It's like you want to be told everything's gonna be all right.
That'd be cooked.
Went through my insurance.
75% of the population probably suck.
A lot of people would freak out.
A lot of people would freak out,
but my man,
all the people who didn't freak out,
even if they did freak out,
they'd probably learn something from it and everybody would come back with a
reinvigorated sense of who we are and how we interface with each other on this
planet.
How many thought about that?
How many times have you done it?
He's done a lot.
Tion seven times.
Mushrooms.
Yeah.
And bump been DMT and mushrooms both about the same times
you have it.
You have a lot.
Hundreds,
hundreds.
I mean I've been doing it since I was 15 so he's worse poster boy ever from
mushrooms.
Right.
This motherfucker,
he's just like the Mayans.
Do you worship Poom serpents now?
No.
That's crazy man.
That's a lot.
I've never done it.
Well I used to do acid a lot,
but then I started doing,
I switched just in my Sherman slam when I was like,
it's like I was doing them all bros,
but I went to Marlboro Lights.
Yeah,
I switched to just mushrooms,
you know.
That's how I took my non-reality.
Yeah.
As you think about doing it in Montana when I was there last weekend,
but I was like that's a heavy a place to do it.
A bad ass.
But there's,
to me there's people,
there was people there by the way,
I didn't mean to tell you about this yet.
There was at the hotel,
there was these two guys on motorcycles and they had like this little girl that
was like four years old and they were like checking in and I was like behind
them.
So you're riding on a motorcycle with a four year old.
Yeah,
it was weird man.
And so you could do that,
right if you were in charge of a four year old and you can probably take them on
a bus.
I don't know if this legal and so the good and that hotel and they're like,
yeah,
we needed a bedroom.
And they're like,
how many beds?
And are just like one.
And I was like,
wait,
there's two guys in a little girl.
And I'm like,
okay.
You know,
like that's all I can afford.
I mean,
beds.
I mean Ben,
Oh,
you could get it isn't,
it?
Doesn't it costs more money for a room too.
But usually I don't think it does,
but what are,
uh,
and then later I saw them again and they were like in the pool.
One of the guys was in port,
the looker on,
he goes,
you're the,
I'm the best uncle ever write their daughter or,
or deer.
And I'm like,
is he saying that louder on purposes cause I'm walking by or something.
It was just really odd.
He was putting on a show like you can't uncle and then he's really,
it was,
it was really awkward.
Anyway,
so then I was like,
you know what,
I'm not gonna eat mushrooms here.
I'm just going to
be really aware of your environment.
You want to start fucking around with,
you already have like some thoughts going on that are negative or something you
don't want to.
I think this is how I would recommend you go about it.
Number one,
fucking,
if anybody wants to do anything psychedelic,
if you wanted to have like a guideline of how to have a psychedelic experience,
number one plan on doing it.
Or someone would say you're gonna give yourself x amount of time and then you're
going to do it.
And in between that,
take care of your health.
Eat good foods,
don't eat anything fast up fast though.
The day you do it fast,
the day you do it,
but keep your body clean like you'll feel,
feel better,
do some yoga,
do some yoga like the day before you do any sort of a psychedelic experience.
If you could do it for a couple days,
you know a week for like two weeks and then have the experience.
You want to be relaxed,
you want to be as calm and as at peace with yourself and then I would recommend
if you can get to a tank and do,
do an isolation tank.
Yes,
tripping balls and find your,
cause you could find yourself in the tank and then when you meet yourself,
when you're on mushrooms,
you won't be as shocking because you were,
you'd already found yourself in the tank.
You're like,
okay,
here I am again.
Okay with this time I'm ready for this and I'm going to escape through this.
I'm going to realize what this is all about because in a tank you could always
just stop it.
You can't stop the mushroom trip in the tank.
If you're freaking out in the tank,
you could just open your eyes,
stand up and get out and you're a sober like that.
It's instantaneous.
It's cause it's all,
it's,
it's a natural psychedelic experience and your body can snap right back to
normal,
not tripping,
just tank,
tank,
tank by itself as a trip.
You don't need to do anything.
Small Hall,
just a little bit too hits is all you need.
Go in that tank and you've done it.
You've done the tank,
right.
Never
got no balls.
Want to try that balls with a razor.
They had drained out.
Honestly to me it seems like I would probably enjoy it but it's like I get,
I get the idea in my head and I'm like,
yeah,
I'm sure it'll be relaxing and nice.
I've talked about it too much and now it's,
it's fucked in.
He'll never be able to go into it because he gets in there and just be thinking
about me talking about [inaudible] will pop in my face and I'll go through a of,
I do want to try on a torrent cricket.
You shouldn't try it.
A long time ago.
She doesn't try.
Then once you do that,
then you're prepared.
Then you got to prepare yourself,
have a couple of tanks,
experiences,
then jump into the wonderful world of mushrooms,
but not until then prepare yourself and that's the problem man.
That's the problem with it being illegal.
If that shit was legal,
we could open up centers and we could fix people.
We could help a lot of people.
Not Wheat,
not me.
I'm not opening up shit.
Don't ask me.
No,
I'm not joining your business.
no,
not a limited LLC.
No,
no.
I ain't got no time.
I mean we as in the human race,
there was a lot of streams.
I think this is,
I was in Asheville,
North Carolina.
He was a lot of shootings up.
They allowed US rooms.
There was a cool place for Schumann.
Yeah man.
And there was this,
I had a great,
I did the Asheville comedy festival this past weekend,
this past weekend.
This past weekend.
Really?
I didn't even know they had a comedy.
So there who,
who you up there with?
It was called laugh.
You're Asheville off is the name of the festival.
It's clever.
Play on words.
By the way,
I'm taking my Alpha brainwave formula right now.
I'd take three.
These are the,
these are our brain are super brain pro earlier.
That's why strong feel stupid.
By the way.
Chris is coming into town next month,
Chris,
anymore.
I know.
Change his name to Aubrey seem who,
what?
We can show you positive and negative examples of drugs.
I'm a much nicer person,
but because of drugs,
me,
I'm much nicer,
much more introspective.
But you know,
Brian's done mushrooms a hundred times and listened to him talk and then he got
our friend Chris who changed his name to Aubrey.
Yeah.
After he had some,
uh,
I'll ask experiences.
Seriously.
Deep dig,
dig deep into the jungles of the mind to the point where he wanted to stop being
the person who he was.
So he changed his fucking name.
Shazamm did you see a coffer brain formula?
It's coming out soon.
Did he send you the pictures of
hangover credits?
Don't say that.
Don't talk.
Is that,
what is that?
What is my,
my shit that we're going to be selling.
It's a nootropics and what it is in ward,
we're going to be,
we're done with this.
He's coming the end of July,
July,
early August.
Um,
and then we're going to,
it will,
it'll launch right after that.
What it is is it's basically the highest level brain nutrients that we could
find mixed them all together.
And Chris,
excuse me,
Aubrey worked very hard on this formula and tweaked it and you know,
it's basically all the information's available online and all this stuff is
available.
We don't have,
we don't have anything.
There's nothing in here that you can't buy individually.
So I mean,
if you can't afford this or if you know you want to try it yourself,
you can always just find out what the ingredients are and go replicate it
yourself.
But what we've done is we put it all together into one pill form and you take it
and it does something,
I don't know exactly what you could say it does,
but it makes you feel sharper,
release your brain fire better.
Oh,
for sure.
It makes me feel less tired when I have jet lag.
When I check into hotels,
I take three of them as soon as I land and I,
I always feel much better.
I feel much more relaxed when I wake up.
It's weird,
dude.
My dreams are insane.
Wait,
that's why I had my Arnold Schwarzenegger dream.
Take this too.
Yeah.
I've,
I don't know what revision that one is.
This is the newest of the newest.
I'm on the,
I had the first revision stuff is amazing.
What's it called again?
Well,
we have,
let me see what we're calling it right now.
It's Alpha is calling an Alpha,
so it's done on it labs.
Oh Man.
it.com or on it labs.
Is it on it labs?
I think it's just on it dot.
Maybe a hold on.
But they also make a product called roll on and roll off.
When I do shrooms,
I do row on before I do showrooms.
And then the next day it's to balance out your neurochemistry.
Yeah.
It's on at.com the balance out your fucking brain juice.
So,
um,
and I think we just crashed the server,
but did we?
Yeah.
Shit.
Oh,
but Ashfield back to Asheville.
Great.
Uh,
it was just,
it was,
it's a really cool festival because it's,
you know,
it's smaller than like the big festivals are just,
they're fun,
they're really well run,
but they're massive.
They're massive,
huge things where it's like,
you know,
there's countless shows going on and then everything is like,
you almost lose kind of,
you know,
sense of where you are and like where am I supposed to be?
Right,
right,
right.
And this is small and it's the fifth year they did,
he'd been to Montreal that that's the biggest one.
Right.
Well I did Melbourne a few months ago.
Dad Is,
I think so initially it's huge.
Huge.
I heard that a lot of the international guys are really bad.
Uh,
ah.
I mean I didn't see that many shows.
I saw like,
cause I was doing shows.
So it was just like,
you know,
we check out some shows.
I didn't even hear that.
I'm just talking shit.
Oh,
he realize
I want to see if he can talk some shit.
Try to pull you into a sheepdog,
man.
I always root for people in other countries to be hilarious.
I know,
I saw some really funny,
I it this Irish Dude,
fuck,
I forget his name,
who was hilarious and it didn't put on a traditional standup show.
It was more like a performance.
Like in one sense I've just,
that like he,
he brought people on stage and he would do shit,
but he was just genuinely funny,
like a funny guy and like,
you know,
like he like music cues would come on and he'd fucking Scottish.
That they have a good sense of humor.
Great sense of humor.
Yeah.
Billy Connolly Guy,
he's a solid standup.
Australians were,
they were all the crowds were great.
Everybody was great.
Do you ever feel like a English comics get extra props because their accent like
this certain certain dudes to get like extra credit?
Yeah,
sure.
And I also feel like they give themselves extra credit for being clever.
Like they'll kind of be like,
hmm.
Like you didn't get that dumb shit.
Well that was fucking brilliant thing that I just said.
Absolutely.
Stewart lead.
Do you know who he is?
The English guy.
Interesting stuff.
Very funny stuff.
Yeah.
But I always wonder like how would that translate in America?
Because he has this really slow style that sort of depends on everyone paying
attention and everyone being polite.
You know,
there's more of that in the audiences,
like definitely in Australia where like at least at these festival shows where
you get like a very polite listening audience.
Like they're very polite.
They're even the rowdy people in England are polite.
Yeah.
You know,
I've had some shows where people yelling out crazy shit,
but they were polite in how they were doing it,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
I'm doing a break.
Go home,
Yank please.
They weren't that bad.
No one was being mean.
They're just yelling shit out.
But I'm doing Birmingham just trying to figure out the date,
so I'm going to do it with Doug Benson and uh,
yeah,
it was a UFC in Birmingham.
So in a book,
something England in England.
Yeah.
November.
I did that.
I did Birmingham with Russell Peters.
Yeah.
Birmingham's awesome.
Yeah,
I did that a while.
That was his ship.
Yeah.
For 7,500 people is to now that was the warmup for the arena.
Did you do?
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
Wow.
Yeah.
We warmed up for 7,000 Russell Peters is the biggest stand up comic in the world
and people don't even realize that.
They don't even realize it.
I know a lot of people that have no idea who he is and it's crazy to me.
I'm like,
you don't know who Russell Peters is like you've never heard that name.
Like you go into another country and you say that name where you go,
you know like put his name on on the staples center or whatever the fucking sell
out 18,000 seats,
we'll sell out.
Do I think,
did I tell you,
I told somebody that like,
you know,
his audience was really nice at Otu especially it was like he's packed the o two
arena to tell jokes.
Right,
right.
And you have,
you do it like they're like 20 minutes and set goes well and you get laughed and
you're like,
this is amazing.
You finished and they give you like a nice applaud.
And then you think you have a gauge for how loud that's going to be.
You know what I mean?
Like when you're in a club and you hit a punch on you're like wow,
I mean if you really kill you're like so that's how like it can get loud and
like you gauge how loud that is.
I thought that because I had gotten laughs during my set like well that's what
it'll sound like man.
When they said they had an intro to him coming on stage and the intro was
prerecorded by Michael Buffer.
Okay.
The ring announcer who and he does like let's get like a whole buildup.
That place fucking exploded.
Like they were like the Beatles are alive and they're here and like you guys are
going to see them for one show only screaming that made all the hair on your
neck stand up,
goosebumps and you're like,
like you crouch cause the noise is overwhelming.
It was that.
It was like they said Buck and Jesus has walked into the building.
I'm going to ask Bruce Buffer to introduce me on my next special,
how tight is that?
I feel like I've got to have Joey Diaz do it because Joey Diaz has done everyone
that I've ever done everything that I've ever done except for my Houston spa,
a CD that I recorded in 99.
Joey Diaz has introduced me to,
it doesn't get much better than that.
I bypass the comedy works in Denver.
I love you,
but you won't put,
Joey d is on the menu.
So I'm doing the,
I'm doing a theater and uh,
what am I doing?
Don't just put it up today.
It's on your website and Twitter.
It's non Ustream son.
It's um,
we're doing a theater in um,
uh,
Denver,
Colorado.
The paramount theater night.
Joey Diaz can finally do it.
Every time I've gone to,
uh,
to the comedy works in Denver.
Joey can't work the comedy works.
You had some sort of a disagreement with somebody back in the day?
Fortunately,
so I hit my weed at the comedy works.
Okay.
Can we go back two minutes?
Yeah,
we can do a set,
maybe a late night set Saturday night.
That's possible.
I'll be there in a couple of weeks.
I'll grab before.
No,
I won't be at the club.
I'll be in a different club,
will be at the Denver Improv,
but I'll,
I'll go over there and grab you find that ones going to the comedy works 23.
Denver comedy works.
We could find out who's there and if they're cool,
we can hang with them.
Yeah,
that'd be cool.
We can find you guys go,
uh,
the Denver one is going to be in,
September 23rd.
Okay.
Should we fund Denver is fucking awesome,
but I'm going to get you in a [inaudible].
I'm going to want to move there again.
Then I'm gonna start getting apocalyptic.
Fucking worry about stocking up on water and shit and hunting elk.
That's what happens.
But that was a crazy place.
I saw your place.
I'll get a little,
yeah,
you went up there with me.
That was crazy,
man.
Did you,
would you just think I was crazy for moving there?
No.
What did you think when you went up there though?
It had to be a weird,
I mean,
when someone says,
Hey,
I'm on,
I'm gonna take you on a ride to the top of a mountain,
down a dirt road,
the square,
I'm going to sleep with my kids at night.
I thought like,
my real reaction was,
this is awesome.
I wish I was in a position that I could do something like this.
That was my genuine,
I didn't see it as like,
what the fuck is he doing?
I was like,
Oh man,
I wish I could fucking do this too.
That was honestly how I felt.
There's two types of people.
There's people that thought that way like me and then there's people thought
like,
what the fuck going on?
It was really cool.
But once I'm also like kind of antisocial,
like personally and like I'm,
I'm,
I like speak kind of isolation and privacy.
Yeah,
yeah,
totally.
Well,
I think the move is you got to have bowls,
you know,
and I think with one of the reasons why a guy like you are a guy,
like I might want to have some peace and quiet alone is because performing can
be kind of overwhelming sometimes.
Yeah.
I think in front of giant groups of people requires this intense amount of
energy and concentration and then you know,
then,
then there's also like meet and greets,
you know,
after shows where it's like,
I want to say hi to everybody I want to,
but then I want it.
Nothing.
Yeah.
I want complete quiet and I like just to sit on a fucking tree,
you know,
a fallen tree and look over at a lake and fucking go fishing.
I love it.
I want to,
I don't want to hear shit man.
I don't want to answer questions about when is Anderson Silva going to fight
fucking this guy because I don't want to hear shit dude by just to watch the
water ripple.
I want Nate,
I want to recharge of my wife because my wife's a comic too.
Like we turn down social invitations almost a hundred percent of the time
because we both,
we both perform and we get home.
We're like,
this is awesome.
We're just going to sit here on the couch.
This is great.
Yeah.
Then the people are like,
no,
but this thing is going to be awesome and we're like,
yeah,
but I don't want to go.
Yeah,
I'm the same way.
Same Way that your house got reminded me of something you'd see on a trapper
keeper.
Like I remember how amazing it the photos,
I never got to see it,
but the photos you singing,
I was like,
Jesus Dude,
his place was amazing as a trip dude.
It was amazing.
The view was incredible back there was that walk that we went on and that lady
that she was such a cool lady that owned the place.
I really liked that lady.
She was awesome and she was really super yoga into yoga.
It's swimming and she was like,
here I stand in like the sun hit it and she had like a wooden thing and she was
like,
I just said,
you know,
you have to give thanks.
Give thanks.
But like I wasn't all into necessarily doing that,
but I love like being able to walk out there,
staying on the side of a mountain.
It's awesome.
And you just didn't like it says a man leaves and uh,
that's a,
that's where people are supposed to be.
You're supposed to at some point in time,
be there and relax and kind of look at it and reset your perspective when you
enter into the hive again.
Yeah.
When you were in the hive,
like we're in the high right now,
you know,
there's,
even though we're,
we're kind of relaxed up here and it's kind of quiet where I live,
there's still millions of people in this area.
There's whether or not you realize it,
you're feeling that you know,
you're,
you're hearing cars move your,
that has an impact on your breathing it well,
yeah,
you're breathing it for sure.
That has a big impact.
And one of the things that I learned from that fucking isolation tank is that
the more you can remove the,
the more you can see things clear and removing things and distractions and bad
things from your environment.
When you have all these things in your environment and they're just there all
the time,
you don't ever think of removing them.
People who live in New York City,
they love it.
I love the action.
I love the sound.
I love this city.
It's amazing city.
You don't realize that city is bombarding you with sensory input,
bombarding you with information that you have to process all the time.
And some people enjoy that and it actually keeps them,
but
two,
to really get a fresh sense of who you are and what life is.
And you just just look at it at a one degree,
different angle.
Just get to the woods,
man,
get to the shore,
could walk along the ocean,
stare out at that.
Never ending water.
There's put,
you need some form of visible nature to humble yourself,
you know?
And in California,
that's one of the reasons why people are such fucking twats.
There's no,
whether you have to deal with ever.
It's just beautiful out here all the time.
It's sunny.
It fucking hardly ever rains.
When it does,
it rains for a day,
you know,
it might rain 10 days a year,
you know?
I mean,
what's the,
what's the most 2020 out of 365 it doesn't fucking rain very often,
man.
We don't have to deal with wind.
We don't have to deal with shit.
Occasionally something lights on fire,
but that's why people are such cons out here because you need nature in your
face.
You need a thunderstorm man.
You need something like that to really like put it in perspective.
Sure.
Man,
I need to be a little more humble about my position here.
Okay.
I'm just a little tiny little organism clean to this giant things hurling
through the galaxy,
you know?
And the best way in my opinion to,
to feel that is to be somewhere natural.
Just interact with the earth somewhere where you could see a fucking forest
somewhere where you could see the ocean and seal fucking water that goes on as
far as you can see.
It's water and it's deep as fuck.
And all that has to do is the earth moves in a wave on a hundred feet high comes
flying at you at 50 miles an hour.
Fucking Jack Too.
You know,
it's,
it changes the way you feel.
Fuck yeah it does.
I did a,
I went to Sun Valley,
Idaho this winter.
That was amazing man.
Oh yeah,
that's gorgeous.
My God,
that like that.
Like you literally angry up there with the legs,
like quarter lane and all that.
And then there's,
there's,
there's these beautiful mountains covered with snow.
Then there's huge trees and you're just,
you go,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Just everything is just like,
yeah,
you're fucking whole physical being like tunes into it and then you relax more.
I wish I could have a house here.
That's the next thought you have fucking out of here.
Yeah.
We have some friends that keep us summer house on,
on the,
on the lake out there and they're always talking about how amazing and they're
in the clothing business.
So they were like real,
you know,
hustle bustle,
real,
always constantly on the go.
And then they go there and just imagine,
decompressing,
imagine doing like a crazy tour where you just do like 60 cities and then you'd
get down,
you're like,
oh,
I want to go sit on the lake.
The husband's done.
He wants to move up there.
He was like,
fuck this fucking crazy town.
And he wants to move up there.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But they have this giant business,
they make like shitloads of money selling clothes.
So they,
they really can't just abandon everything.
They have like a high lifestyle to support,
you know.
But meanwhile they just want to just relax by the water.
Man.
Everybody wants that fucking feeling of,
of real retiring somewhere.
But you don't realize that that is very close to death kind of based.
At least a lot of people have who they are on what they do,
what they do for a living,
what they do for how they interact with people
and feel useful.
And as soon as you like slide away from that and just stay by yourself,
it takes a very,
uh,
a very different mindset to enjoy that without starting to get depressed and
start feeling that you're dying and it's the end of the line for you,
you know?
Yeah.
Cause that is,
it really is putting the brakes on when you move somewhere.
Right.
Cause you,
but maybe it's your,
you're opening up to something else because you're,
instead of like your drive being for accomplishing more work,
like maybe you're just becoming a different type of person.
Yeah.
Still doing some type of work.
I'm saying,
yeah,
you're putting work into yourself more.
Well,
if you could figure out how to a hunter s Thompson it and how to just live up
there and then in travel in whenever you wanted and then interact with the
people and then head back out to your shelter.
Where would he live?
He lived in a woody creek in Colorado.
Colorado is a near Aspen,
really more remote even sort of than I was living because aspen is trickier to
get to,
you know,
you fly right into Denver,
you drive an hour and you're in Boulder,
you drive 20 minutes or in the mountains.
I mean it's that this is that easy.
It's literally you're an hour and 20 minutes from your car to a where I lived.
That's not hard at all.
You know,
and you're in the fucking woods.
Where he was is a lot more difficult.
He had to fly in to aspen and aspen is like a little tiny ass airplane airport
rather.
And it doesn't,
um,
it's not a good one either.
It's a funky one cause it's like nestled in between mountains and sometimes
people crash.
Like I knew they reroute you all the time too.
Yeah,
they rerouted us when we did the Aspen comedy festival.
They said the winds are too high and there's too much snow and we don't want to
slam into a fucking mountain that we can't see.
They didn't have to worry about that.
They did the Christina this year when she went there.
I did that for Sun Valley and they were like,
airports not working.
Yeah.
Fuck,
get on the bus and enjoy the wing gets wacky up there man.
I knew a dude who lost his friends.
They were in a private jet and they were headed out to aspen.
There were high rollers in the movie business.
Dan.
These guys were like super ballers and they fucking were making millions and
slammed into a mountains that you had that like if you were to get like that,
it seems like the worst thing is crashing in a private jet.
Like we were like let's do the fucking private jet shit man.
You just,
you putting up crazy money.
That's how a lot of luxury and then you're fucking private jet crashes.
He's like I paid 60 grand for this flight and it crashed into the fucking
mountain.
It's yeah,
private jet is the ultimate ridiculous indulgence is like what does it cost to
fly to Vegas costs like if you want to go first class is like 1000 bucks or 2000
bucks a month I would think more than the thousand cause it's a pretty short
flight.
The most expensive that you can pay for.
And if you wanted to go coach,
it's like a couple hundred bucks,
right?
You can go southwest for like 150 bucks or something crazy.
Or You could spend 15,000 and go in a private jet.
Yeah.
Whoa.
And then there's all the,
there's all the qualified,
like the,
all the different classifications of jet.
Yeah,
small jet,
midsize jet.
How about propeller planes?
Propeller planes,
really luxurious propeller Bryan's we've got you live like you're fucking Ernest
Hemingway flying to Cuba.
And
the,
the ultimate craziest status is like what Oprah has,
which is a bone in your line of Boeing business jet.
So it's actually a converted like seven,
four,
seven or seven seven seven.
Is that what she had?
Yeah.
Where they strip out the entire,
the 60 rose and they have like Air Force One.
So like entertainment area of Judge Room.
Joe,
have you ever been to the Ronald Reagan Museum up in Calabasas?
No.
Never been there.
Go there and get really baked and go to the Ronald Reagan Museum.
They have an air force one there.
And it's so amazing.
I'm like walking through this,
what you're used to.
It's like in Calabasas thousand oaks or somewhere around there.
Somewhere around there.
Yeah,
north.
Is it,
um,
they actually have a plane that you can step into.
Like it's outside.
Yeah.
It's a real air force one.
You go into the side of warehouse and you get to walk through the whole thing
and they,
they put like little,
it was Ronald Reagan's and they put like a little jelly beans on his desk
because he liked jelly beans but doesn't have a one of those little escape pods.
And we would climb in it and then they hit the parachute and he fucking,
the plane falls apart and he escapes.
I can't remember,
but it was pimp,
pimp the what?
I'm sorry.
You weren't even paying and I was reading wasn't,
I was reading the,
the uh,
did they have like,
remember how like I know at least in some movies,
Air Force One had like an escape pod,
the president Pi and it would like hell parachute would deploy or I don't think
this Jet Star Wars.
Yeah.
Bullshit.
I think that's bullshit.
So if the plane crashes,
he's fucked.
They can't save the president.
The uh,
the seven,
eight,
seven,
I believe would get mad.
They'd go,
what can you save the President?
You can't say my little Billy.
I always wondered why they couldn't have fucking parachute.
That's a last resort somewhere on the plane,
just in case there's the whole,
Johnny B said it best.
He goes,
why can't they have a power shoot for the whole fucking place?
That's what he said.
It ties this bro.
This bro,
I can fucking solve a airplane crashes.
What happens?
Playing breaks and sky.
Oh,
you've got a parachute.
He used to just drift to the ground.
What can they do that?
Yeah,
he goes,
what does it cost?
How much is it fucking parachute?
You cheap pricks.
You can't even afford a fucking parachute and makes so much sense,
doesn't it?
It doesn't make sense.
Does that make sense at all?
Because the way of the parachute combined with the way to the puck and play and
you'd probably run out of gas halfway to Idaho,
the shit would fall apart.
We all dude out of whack.
The Boeing business jets range and costs from 47 million to $310 million.
And you know she didn't get the cheap one.
Hell,
Oprah's a ballroom sign.
Blue Tooth right now.
She's got one ladies around her all the time filing her nails,
one on each toe.
They're all white girls to all white girls under 120 pounds.
It's all she asked for.
I want only white workers.
120 pounds or lighter skinny girls.
Pick a tone.
That's what she wants.
The skinniest,
prettiest girls to clean her toes and feet wash cocoa butter on her elbows while
she talks about her fucking $300 million jet,
but she's converted into a disco.
It's fucking nuts.
Right?
Do you think Oprah's game?
Do I know you?
You don't really.
You don't consider it at all?
That's the room,
right?
He's saying she's gay for that Gail jail.
I think she's more asexual and just a a power hungry ego maniac.
Really?
Yeah,
totally.
You don't think she hires chicks would come over and eat or box?
She Mike.
I don't know.
She might see the thing that would cause he just tell him yes.
Okay.
A girl think so come over and he Oprah's box.
Uh,
I think she probably has a flat rate.
Like maybe she's like listen,
you know you can work at Wendy's does.
They don't pay much more.
He can eat my box on 10 days.
10 G's.
Sure.
Thinking about 10 each pop.
Yup.
10 g's for a 20 minute session.
Yeah.
And that girl,
that's all she does and she just works for Oprah every couple of days.
But she has like a little thing but she's like I'll give you a little extra if
you make the pussy pop.
Like she has like a little tag on it for and the goes like,
what's that mean?
Do you go in?
She calls it a pussy.
Yeah for sure.
Yeah.
Really you think starts staying box or stag box.
Cause you know sometimes when she gets like she gets back to her old southern
route and she'd be like,
girl you know this shit.
I shouldn't say shit but like this is done.
Let's just ground like she'll really play it up.
I think when she's in bed she's probably like get that push to get a guarantee.
You if you could encapsulate the smell of a Oprah Winfrey post binge diarrhea
blast,
cause she knows she must go on a binge.
She's drops heat,
she shirts,
she gets heavy bro and shit goes down.
She got real skinny for a while and then she just pumps up and there's some meat
and going on their son.
There's a lot of stress and that's how she,
if you could encapsulate it into like a,
a something that you could open and smell her shit,
I guarantee you people would buy it.
Yeah,
that'd be fascinated.
People are,
I love grape juice for a certain amount of money.
If you just,
as long as you made it reasonable,
if you said smell Oprah shit for $1,
you would make millions.
Yeah.
It's all a cost.
Like a buck.
That's not,
that's not reasonable.
It's less than what we have a car it,
you might make five,
6 million bucks off that product.
Sure.
Why do we do it?
Why can't they encapsulate record smells the way they record sound and visual.
It's just because there's not that much of a demand for it.
It seems like they should be able to do that by now.
Like they should be able to put it a smell into some sort of a reusable medium.
You know,
visual medium is like,
they can record video.
You can watch that video.
It gets in through your eyes,
you know,
why can't they record a smell?
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
cause you ever done the like the film capsule thing.
You're doing that before.
What's that like the 35 millimeter film cart,
you know the little black thing,
Fortinet and then you encapsulate it.
Yeah.
You can close it that far.
It'll stay in their own way.
Yes it will.
Yes.
He will.
Confident.
I would bet on him be amended with cups and jars.
You can do with jars too.
I've tried to,
you know,
and you also didn't fart.
Like you got to really be into farting.
I [inaudible] I farted on Christina the other day when you were there.
I,
yes.
We're all walking,
hanging out of
the office and I'd just trailed her whole leg,
the whole
damn dude.
Why don't you find that his wife don't fart on my life.
So it was respectful,
man.
My daughter parts on me all the time.
We were watching TV shows with her.
She's sitting on my lap and she just starts farting.
Three year olds don't give a fuck,
but you just go.
It's just foreign to me.
She goes,
yeah,
that's farts on you.
That's gotta be the only time that doesn't bother you.
If your daughter,
you're like,
yeah,
it is what it is.
You know I gotta I gotta wipe her but still make sure it's done right.
Flush.
Flush your logs.
If a baby's log,
a three year old baby,
if the your log was in proportionate,
it would be the size of your fucking thigh.
Oh yeah.
Cause they have big old shit.
Shit.
They,
they eat so much.
You know the kids are always hungry growing,
so they just fucking packed that food and it comes out like a,
like a grown up shit.
Yeah.
You tried to do the math,
like that's ridiculous.
I love taking,
she's going to have a little Tommy running around.
You and Christina at some point live rounds in there and get the party rolling.
Definitely at some point.
I definitely want kids right now.
Great couple.
She is 35 that's when you got to start thinking about it.
Yeah.
You got to start thinking about,
you know your,
your,
your window.
I don't know what the window is for it to be healthy,
but we're going to get on it.
Yeah,
we're going to get on it too.
Yeah.
I should fill in the whole thing.
The porn right up to it.
Oh yeah.
It could be a new reality show by the time your kid is born.
That will be passe.
Kim Kardashians will have already had like a cervix reality show.
Kim Kardashians,
a new show.
It's going to be a microchip little camera where you can just see the black
dicks going in after the other.
That's the whole show.
The whole show is a 24 hour internet cam inside her pussy.
It's all Wifi and it and it,
it's all fucked up.
You would pay for that.
Would you pay for that?
And that was in the playboy channel.
If they agreed,
if a girl agreed to do that,
please someone out there steal this idea.
Get a girl who looks like Kim Kardashian,
pretended to Kim Kardashians,
lie to me,
say this may or may not be Kim credit actually is pussy and get a girl to put a
24 hour webcam inside a box.
But he stole the idea from me the other day,
by the way.
I didn't know.
Well,
yeah,
I could totally be parallel thinking for years.
I've said,
and I even said it just a,
uh,
last week on the podcast,
but I sit on one of your old old podcasts.
I can't remember that I had this idea that called snail mail.
And where I thought about when,
when my grandmother was still alive that she doesn't get,
have a computer,
but I wanted to be able to like write an email and then send it to a company and
that company would write it out and send her like a handwritten letter,
you know?
So it'd be easy for me to write letters to my grandmother for a charge the other
day.
I had a Freddy Lockhart podcast and I talked about it and then two yesterday,
gizmodo.com said this like artists guy did that and he's called snail mail to
email or email to snail mail.com or something like that and that's what this new
company gone.
Well,
if they stole from you,
I hope the fucking day crashed to the ground.
Bryan's guess not cool man.
That's not cool at all.
How long have they been around?
I think since yesterday.
And you allow them to steal it from you.
You don't want a piece of that.
There's no money.
He's doing it for free so it's like more of an art project.
I think those guys for your idea,
you welcome it.
You have your hand.
Okay,
good.
That's nice.
That's very thoughtful of it.
It's nice you're,
you're contributing to the world,
right?
You little wacky ideas.
I've had time.
I would have done it myself.
If you don't know a and you can't get enough of Brian,
you're like,
God,
who's that dude stumbling through a sentences?
I fucking love him.
His stone.
You can.
Yeah,
he has two stone.
Brian is a way smoother talker before he does the podcast,
but I knew that I was going to get past that third hit his way and he's
impulsive.
He's gonna say yes and I know he shouldn't have it,
but part of me wants to see him take you to give me a third head,
gave you that third hand realize no,
I took the third hit too.
I'm just starting to come back.
I'm on a Machu Picchu high.
The entire time we were talking I was thinking about Machu Picchu.
Plan your trip,
man.
You plan your trip.
Yeah.
That's hard.
When you have little ones,
I don't think they'd be down.
I got to tell him Mickey mouse is at the top as what I'll do.
I'll hire some dudes,
dress like Mickey and Donald and there'll be waiting for me at the top of my
jewelry shoes
and the kids would like,
Daddy,
let's go back.
I can't breathe.
It's not the ideal place for little kids to see the big rocks.
I'm here for the big rocks.
You're fucks.
You don't let your kids have lemonade stands.
I saw lemonade stand the other day and it blew my mind.
I was like,
wait,
you gotta be parents?
These kids on the side of a street and that's an open item shopping.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
And there was no parents anywhere.
Where about after to the house?
The poor guy
and in Brooklyn.
Did you hear about this?
Where the,
the little kid asks for directions.
He's on his way home from school.
He's eight years old,
asked for directions they can't find them and they find video of the kid at the
playground talking to some man that go to the man's house.
The kids chopped up in his frigerator file.
No.
Yeah cause an orthodox Jew too,
which really shocked the Jewish community because the other kid was a Hasidic
Jew and it's you,
a very tight knit Jewish community.
There's,
this guy was an orthodox Jew,
killed this fucking kid and chopped him up.
And I did think it was like,
it was weird.
Like yesterday,
I'm driving down like Glendale Boulevard and it's like sundown and you see like
a saw two girls that were probably like,
I dunno,
maybe like 1213 just walking down the street and it's not like a bad
neighborhood.
And you're like,
you shouldn't be walking down in Glendale Boulevard.
Like you're too young.
Like they,
like cars are flying by and there's,
there's,
it's,
it's still la.
There's Weirdos on any street.
Just walking around.
It does make me go like,
man,
I thought like,
I would definitely not be cool with my kid walking around.
You know,
you live well just like that street.
Like it's not a,
it's not,
that wasn't like,
it's not a residential street man.
Like it's,
it's a,
it's like a highway almost.
It's why people always want to go to the suburbs once they have children.
It's like,
wow,
this high,
this is just too crazy.
Yeah.
I sort of admire people that raise their kids in New York
City.
I'm like,
wow,
what a wild ride that's gotta be for kids,
you know,
to grow up in the hub of North American civilization.
Yeah.
I mean New York City is unlike any other city.
You can call all a la a city all you want,
but it's really not.
It's a,
it's a destination to destination.
It is.
La is an area,
it's a place,
but it's not a city.
New York City is a fucking city man.
When you're in staying in a hotel and you open your window and everywhere around
you or 60 70 stories,
skyscrapers and you're looking down to the ground,
there's fucking millions of people looking out their windows and looking at you
and you see this giant thing that's created and on this little island that's a
fucking city and others,
that's the human experience and its and its highest rpm form and you know
there's giant construction where everything's built up,
you know,
they don't have any room to go east and West so they go north and south.
You know what the fuck.
That's a weird place to all east coast cities have that a different vibe and
feel then like out here like yeah you know San Francisco is a proper city like
in a tight kind of thing.
But like you know like Philly,
Baltimore,
New York,
those are like,
those are cities where there's,
you can feel the city is alive here.
You don't really hear the,
yeah,
the city,
the city is filled with pukes too.
Yeah.
It was filled with people that are trying to get famous,
so the vibe of the city's all fucked up.
Totally.
That's right,
la.
I said it.
How about you just suck it Brian,
we doing tweeting.
It's the end of this fucking Goddamn podcasts and she was thinking it was fun.
It's always fun all the time.
It's a girl and if you think Tommy is hilarious when you hear him talk on the
podcast,
you can also check him on his podcast,
which is your mom's house that you can catch on the desk squad network and a my
favorite ones to do it to of course use hilarious and so is his wife and they do
it together,
which is a little bit pussy whipped,
but we're going to let them slide,
you know it is what it is.
It is.
It's great.
I love it.
His wife is super cool.
I remember when I met your wife,
your wife was going on at the naughty show and there was a fucking a girl beaten
a dude with a belt right before your,
your chick went up.
And I was talking to her and she's like,
what the fuck am I going to do with it?
How am I going to follow this?
And I like,
wow,
she's got to follow that.
Like that's going to be hard.
Like,
you know,
these people are screaming and cheering and she just rocked it.
She went up,
brushes,
sued.
She's hilarious man.
Super relaxed and super confident and he follow her on Twitter to go give out
her Twitter.
And Twitter is a at Christina,
Christina,
Christina p.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
she's,
she's awesome.
She's hilarious.
If you really want to see Tom at his finest,
you got to go see him do stand up.
He's at the Ice House this weekend with me,
but it's sold the fuck out,
son.
Yo,
me and Joey Diaz and Tommy Segura.
But uh,
when else can they see you?
Where are you going to be out?
Ah,
well next Tuesday I'm going to be in Montreal for the festival.
In Tuesday night I'm to do Ari show at midnight in Montreal.
Wow.
Oh beautiful.
I'm doing other shows throughout the week at the festival.
Like I'm doing a HBO Canada Show,
a couple of bucks,
uh,
best affairs shows and I'll try to post those like as soon as I know them.
But definitely Ari show Tuesday night and the week after what is already show
called.
It's a storytelling show.
Where's it at?
I don't know.
I don't.
So it's in Montreal.
In Montreal.
If you want to find it,
ask Ari Shaffir ar I s h a f f I r on Twitter.
Ask Him and he'll tell you what the fuck is up.
I'm proud of art.
He's,
he's doing a lot of shit.
He's doing shows and you can tell like,
he,
like,
he's really like,
like striding in his lane.
Like he's really fucking blowing up.
His standup is getting better to everything.
Everything's coming together.
He's doing fantastic.
The week after though,
I'll be in Denver at the Denver Improv.
Oh Shit.
Son.
August 4th through the seventh.
And you can travel with your wife or who you are.
I know who I'm working with.
I just know that I'm doing it.
Nice.
Yeah.
Do they have you headline in there?
It better.
Yes.
Dirty bitches.
Yeah.
So that'll be,
that'll be a lot of fun.
So paramount theater,
September 23rd,
Joe Diaz returns to Colorado home,
tried to blacklist him.
We would not allow it this Sunday.
A Michael Chavela.
We'll be doing a podcast with me.
So Brian's,
Oh,
I love Mike.
He's a great guy and he's going to hang out at the house and his missus was
going to hang out with my messages and I'm going to throw it out on a fucking
great man.
Yeah,
great.
I saw them in Melbourne and he took me to a very beautiful bathroom,
a beautiful bathroom.
I haven't to tell you about it.
Okay.
He's a great guy.
I love that dude.
So that's it for this week.
Next week we got,
um,
on the 27th,
uh,
Giorgio sucralose from ancient aliens and it's going to be on the podcast and a
fucking fight up for that.
And we've got a bunch of other people that were going to try to get in here.
Um,
cause a few fighters,
a few comics,
few different things Brian ever saw.
I think he's gonna do it.
We're going to,
I gotta talk to him and we're going to get may him back as soon as may has done
filming the ultimate fighter and we've got a lot of shit going down pitches and
uh,
the new studio,
which we should be moving into very soon.
I gotta I gotta as soon as I'm done here,
I'm going right there.
I'm looking at shit so that,
yeah,
that's,
you got to come with me,
bitch.
I can't come on son.
You have a new studio.
We're going to make a new studio.
We've got to make a studio in a,
we're going to do something in an actual office building.
No Shit.
Yeah man,
I can't keep doing this in my fucking my office.
My kids were in the background screaming.
I feel like a Douche bag dad that I want them to be quiet in their own house.
Yeah.
In one way it's kind of cool cause I like hearing like a little kid screams in
the background every now and then.
Well,
right now we're to bring these skanks over the house either.
Let's be honest,
ladies and gentlemen,
that's part of the program.
Or the program is a,
I can't bring any skanks over here.
And this is rocky.
Doesn't like it.
The only time we've had skanks,
excuse me,
uh,
questionable people.
Or we did it over at Brian's house.
So by now,
you know who you are.
Yeah.
So Andy Dick,
that's,
that's how the cookie crumbles.
Hookers.
All right.
Listen,
love you guys.
I can't wait for a Pasadena Ice House this weekend.
According to the website.
It's sold out.
But if you go there were,
you know who the fuck knows?
There might be some tickets laying around calling them.
What the fuck do I know?
Can't wait to see everybody and I'll see you Sunday.
All right,
let me come on.
Give me a kiss.
She's angry.
Oh,
that's right.
I always forget.
Um,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast was brought to you by the fleshlight.
Go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and you enter in
the code name Rogan.
You will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
And then what you do is you,
um,
you take it and you open up the box and you stick your penis inside of it and
you go like task.
And then you go to sleep.
It's the best.
So we love you.
We hope you love us back.
Bye Bye.
Hi.